pour le moment on ne connaît pas encore
les détails des funérailles quand est ce
qu'elle conteste qu'ils auront lieu mais
ça va être très gros là sébastien on
parle d'un règne de 70 ans c'est le plus
long règne d'un monarque dans l'histoire
c'est quelqu'un qui a marqué non
seulement l'histoire des britanniques
mais l'histoire un peu du monde entier
si vous voulez puis elle a été témoin
également dû l'histoire elle a été reine
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
enfin après la deuxième guerre mondiale
ensuite lors de la décolonisation la cré
le common word qu'elle affectionnait
particulièrement le canada en fait
partie et puis bon elle a été elle a été
là récemment durant la pandémie les gens
l'ont dit que c'était vraiment la
personne qui les a consolé le plus elle
a livré un discours en disant écoutez
c'est difficile mais on va y arriver
donc elle a toujours et avait si vous
voulez cette espèce de présence pour
rassurer les britanniques cette célèbre
phrase qui comme une carriole et bien
leur a fait jusqu'au bout
oui elle était devenue reine
d'angleterre le 6 février 1952 à la
suite du décès du roi georges 6 donc de
février 52 à
2022 en septembre 2000 25 de plus de 70
ans d'ailleurs on avait célébré son
jubilé de 70 ans il ya quelques semaines
à peine à z merci beaucoup vous restez
là si jamais il ya d'autres informations
qui vous viennent marc laurendeau qui
connaît bien donc la monarchie la
royauté est avec nous marque merci
d'être écroués dans nos studios c'est
vraiment ça
parlez nous de la reine elizabeth ii de
sa vie pas facile
projeté donc sur ce trône à un très
jeune âge oui 25 ans en fait et
ça ne va pas être elle lancé vivement le
la démission du roi l'application
devrais-je dire du roi édouard 8 qui a
l'a amené sur le drone finalement et
c'est elle se prépare est quand même
parce qu'à partir du moment où son père
lui avait succédé elle se préparait elle
le dit parfois
j'aimerais apprendre autre chose la
constitution c'est à dire que c'était
des des précepteurs qui lui enseignait
pour votre action
portrait global du personnage parce que
c'est ça c'est un ici la plupart de nos
auditeurs n'ont connu quelques hommes
rennes vous et moi moi j'ai connu
georges 6 brièvement mais vous n'avez
connu que la reine elizabeth ii c'est le
cas pour la plupart de nos auditeurs à
c'est une coupure marquantes elle y la
mémoire institutionnelle de la monarchie
elle connut une quinzaine de premier
ministre c'est elle qui gardaient le cap
au fond qui avait le sens du devoir et
qui bien que la famille royale et des
péripéties on s'ennuyait sébastien avec
les médias
ne piège des scandales dans la famille
une année horrible où le chat tout son
château de windsor a brûlé de ne pas et
où il ya eu des scandales de vie privée
dans la famille dire sans la
procédure récemment c'est le principe du
plus justement qui a fait l'objet d'un
scandale d'ordre sexuel non il faut bien
le dire et qui a été que peser lourd sur
la monarchie mais elle elle garder le
cap c'est la raison principale pour
laquelle les gens adhéraient à la
monarchie c'était sa conduite exemplaire
sa lucidité et je vous dire sébastien je
suis surpris qu'elle meure jeu j'ai été
pris de surprise lâche arrivé ici en
cours un presque je m'attendais pas à ce
que ça arrive maintenant 94 ans sa mère
a vécu jusqu'à 102 elle elle surveillait
beaucoup sa santé elle se soignait se
faisait opérer quand c'était le temps
elle n'avait pas d'habitude excessive
c'était pas quelqu'un qui avait une vie
débridée alors je suis surpris que ça
arrive maintenant contenu de l'hérédité
calle avec et réduit lui permettent de
vivre plus longtemps mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que le garder jusqu'à la fin
cette très grande lucidité et son sens
du devoir alors
oui il avait 2 c'est un sou dire on a
fêté son jubilé de diamant où vous
souvenez elle était sur l'irak
c'est vrai on avait dessiné pour ce
jubilé des barques qui j'ai
roulé mais se trouvait à naviguer sur la
tamise et même s'il pleuvait elle
restait debout on lui avait préparé un
siège elle ne s'assoyait pas elle
recevait la pluie pendant que park ont
fêté son jubilé et c'était un symbole de
son sens du devoir quand je précise
qu'elle avait 96 ans marc
96 ans donc son décès aujourd'hui et pas
plus tard qu'hier je pense elle recevait
la nouvelle première ministre
britannique les strauss à balmoral
justement puis quand vous dites et elle
se tenait debout et on a vu une photo
d'elle où elle était en effet deux bouts
avec sa canne évidemment mais recevant
la nouvelle première ministre
britannique qui doit d'ailleurs
s'adresser à la population au cours des
prochaines minutes on attend aussi une
conférence de presse où enfin une
déclaration de justin trudeau on va vous
présenter ça évidemment quelle était la
relation marque des britanniques avec la
monarchie parce que vous la décrivez
comme un espèce de rock n'est ce pas là
la reine elizabeth ii
les mais en même temps il y avait des
problèmes et des questions sur la
monarchie comme un lit britannique quel
genre de relation avait et il avec la
monarchie mais elle était un peu comme
une mère
queen mum sa mère étant décédée elle
était elle était le coeur de la famille
royale et la relation était très bonne
beaucoup du prestige de la monarchie
sébastien si on fait que
l'occupante celle qui est sur le trône
occupent eux c'est à dire avec beaucoup
de dignité je dois vous vous vous aider
rompre avec dignité je m'excuse les
trois premières
nations
ce qui est des causes
justes noces en
chine
nous sommes maintenant une nation
prospère et dynamique et
c'est marie elle nous a toujours faire
la stabilité la force dont nous avions
besoin elle était l'esprit même de la
grande bretagne et cet esprit va être
pérennisée par son régne elle eut le
règne le plus long de notre histoire
ça a été vraiment incroyables brouillent
autant de dignité de grâce pendant 70
ans
sa vie dévouée à nation va au-delà de
nos mémoires vivantes et elle a été
admiré et aimé par les gens du
royaume-uni du monde entier elle a été
une inspiration personnelle pour moi et
pour bien des britanniques est son
dévouement de voir est un exemple à
imiter
un peu plus tôt cette semaine à 96 ans
elle était déterminée de s'acquitter ses
responsabilités quand elle m'a nommé
comme 15ème premier ministre de son
règne tout au long de sa vie elle s'est
rendue dans ce plus d'une centaine de
pays elle a touché la vie de millions de
personnes de par le monde
dans les jours difficiles à suivre nous
allons leur assemblée avec nos amis
partout au royaume uni dans le
commonwealth et le monde entier afin de
célébrer sa vie extraordinaire voué au
service de la nation et du monde c'est
une journée difficile mais notre reine
laisse vraiment un legs incroyable la
couronne veut changer de maire comme
c'est le cas depuis plus de mille ans
vers le nouveau monarque est sa majesté
le roi charles iii avec la famille du
roi nous pleurons la perte de sa mère et
à mesure que nous pleurons nous devons
nous rassembler comme nation pour le
soutenir pour l'aider à porter la
responsabilité mais ce qu'il a
maintenant sur ses épaules pour nous
tous et toutes nous lui offrons notre
loyauté et notre dévouement tout comme
sa mère attend dé vous et pour tant
d'années et avec le passage de 7,2 mrd
abete nous passons le flambeau à la
prochaine génération
tout comme sa majesté leur évolué en dix
ans les mots que dieu sauve le roi
la première ministre britannique liz 3
rend hommage à la reine elizabeth 2 qui
est décédé un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
en la décrivant comme le roc sur lequel
la grande bretagne actuelle s'est bâti
et incarné l'esprit de la grande
bretagne dit elle aussi
elle était aimée admirer à travers le
royaume uni notamment pour son
dévouement à ses fonctions passé quelque
chose qui revient souvent lorsqu'il est
question de la reine elizabeth 2 le fait
qu'elle ait été projeté sur ce trône
très jeune âge dans le début vingtaine
et qu'il est occupé ces fonctions là
pendant 70 ans contre vents et marées
nous allons célébrer sa vie dit les
strauss et elle a rendu hommage
également au nouveau roi le roi charles
ii iii dont confirmant d'une certaine
façon qu'il a l'intention de prendre ce
titre de charles et il devient le roi
charles iii marcq rando est il toujours
avec moi toujours oui ou propres moi
cette révélation la scène avec 8,7 pas
été dit de source officielle
effectivement il prendrait le nom de
charles iii vous savez que georges 6
finalement ne s'appelait pas georges
burti albert c'était son nom ait alors
ils ne choisissent pas automatiquement à
partir de leurs prénoms comme la reine
elizabeth au fait il aurait pu le faire
naturellement les les conjectures
allaient dans le sens de dire il va
s'appeler charles iii il ya même eu il
ya quelques années une pièce à new york
s'intitulait une pièce de théâtre qui
s'intitulait charles iii ont été envoyés
sur broadway oui oui oui c'est ça ou la
pièce s'appelait charles iii mais ça
convient tout à fait
et ça c'est une révélation nous allons
vivre désormais sous le règne de charles
iii et c'est tout un chacun
encore une fois nous sur nos pièces de
monnaie sur nos billets de banque va
être quatre visites au canada
rappelez-vous et l éolien particulier
elle a visité toutes les provinces elle
parlait très bien français alors le fait
de la voir disparaître si vite on se
serait dit on qu'on aurait préféré se
faire à l'idée graduellement plutôt que
de voir ça arrivait de d'un coup chaque
lame et déjà on avait des indices matin
sébastien quand on a vu arriver d'un peu
partout puis même de destination
difficile les gens de la famille royale
ces gens là savaient des choses que nous
ne savions pas encore et on comprend que
le buckingham palace veut faire les
choses dans l'ordre aussi ne pas
annoncer le décès tout de suite mais
permettre à la famille par exemple
d'arrivée parce que comme vous le dites
si bien la reine elizabeth ii était en
écosse sa famille je présume était dans
le coin de buckingham palace ou à
londres donc il y avait des gens à
déplacer donc charles
accède au trône à l'âge de 73 ans
postule la suite des choses or on va
revenir sur la vie l'héritage de la
reine elizabeth 2 mais à partir du
moment que de ce moment ci pas sûr
maintenant que se passe-t-il mac
ce qui se passe est évidemment c'est
qu'il va y avoir tout d'abord des
funérailles et c'est la fameuse
opération london bridge arrive à une
proclamation de ce décès ça c'est ce
qu'il faut prévoir pour toutes aux
rituels qui avait été mis en place et
qui s'appliquera pas tout à fait de la
même façon parce que tout ça avait été
fait comme si ce décès nous avait pris
par surprise si on s'était réveillé au
petit matin puis on avait su que la
reine elisabeth était décédé il y avait
même des façon d'annoncer ça sur les
avions figurez vous alors c'était tout
un système de proclamation on va
peut-être raccourcir un certain nombre
d'étapes mais il va y avoir dans les
heures qui viennent proclamation
évidemment vu marc si vous me permettez
d'aidé
des employés d'un château je présume que
cette époque hingham par l'esm est
accrochée sur la clôture du château eu
un message disant que la reine était
décédé et que le prince consort c'est
comme ça qu'on l'appelle et la princesse
consort où le roi concerne la reine
consort oui mais je sais que je vais
vous donner des détails le dessus tout à
l'heure mais chic et nyon kamina
resterez à balmoral ce soir est arrivé à
londres demain donc il ya comme une
espèce de proclamation je sais pas si
c'est le terme exact mais on a annoncé
en accrochant sur la clôture d'un
château le décès de la reine elizabeth
ii je voulais continuer reine consort
ellison que
c'était sud était la solution envisagée
puisque camille cela n'arrive pas au
trône dans la famille royale dans les
principaux postes avec tout à fait une
réputation parfaite toute l'histoire de
diana puis
l'adultère un peu scandale hull qui
avaient précédé tout ça fait qu'on avait
beaucoup de réticences et dans l'est
dans les premières années on disait
rebacca miller vice reine consort mais
dans les dernières années on a été
surpris de lire ça mais il ya eu les
communiqués émis du palais de boké en me
disant que non elle serait effectivement
rennes naturellement celui qui règne
c'est le monarque d'après la la
hiérarchie et la dynastie c'est
naturellement charles mais elle et elle
est plus qu'une reine consort voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est pas quelqu'un qui
va jusqu'à compagnie c'est son épouse
qui partagent un certain nombre d'aidés
des pouvoirs que j'appellerais
protocolaire chan ne sera pas couronné
immédiatement selon ce qu'on comprend
que la reine elizabeth ii elle son père
était mort le 6 février 1952 et c'est en
juin 53 qu'elle avait été couronnée en
fait elle avait dix titres de rennes
puis challal titre de roi mais le
couronnement lui attend quelques mois
n'est ce pas peut pas toujours aussi
longs ça a été très long dans le cade
elizabeth 2 d'ailleurs dans la série de
crown
quelqu'un comme vous savez pas assez sur
des flics mais également ou au théâtre
dans la pièce où elle meurt une joue et
on voit que il avait 2 soupçonne
churchill de retarder le couronnement de
manière à pas perdre sa majorité en
chambre parce que c'est là rien au fond
qui donne la possibilité de dissoudre le
parlement et de convoquer une élection
et churchill craignent de perdre sa
majorité donc aurait retardé c'est le
soupçon qu'on lui impute dans ces séries
fort bien écrite déçu voire basée sur la
réalité c'est le soupçon qu'on est pas
imputer à churchill mais il ya d'autres
facteurs aussi un mariage pardon ou un
cérémonie de couronnement non point
mariage et était déjà marie une
cérémonie de couronnement
télévisées on n'avait jamais vu ça et il
ya eu une part de négociations aussi
entre churchill qui était pas très
réceptif au début qui s'est fait
convaincre et puis il faut organiser ça
vous que la reine elle même y participer
soit convaincu alors lieu tout ce rituel
là qui a fait que ça a été long ça a été
donc mais
sébastien jusqu'au repos que ce soit ou
sinon d'avoir parce que chara attendu
longtemps charles iii a fallu très
longtemps pour régner aux deux qu'il
veuille perdre de précieux mois de règne
dans une situation comme celle là on met
la machine est plus en place maintenant
pour procéder à l'installation d'accord
on verra d'ailleurs charles atteint donc
accède au trône à l'âge de 73 ans marc
laurendeau merci beaucoup de vous être
récipient studio journée de plaisir on
est prêt si on vous en est reconnaissant
je vous rappelle donc mesdames messieurs
que vous êtes en train d'écouter une
émission spéciale sur la chaîne sur
radio canada et le réseau de
l'information sur le décès d'elizabeth
ii qui a été annoncé au cours de la
dernière heure et demie à une
communication de buckingham palace
disant que la reine était décédée à
balmoral en écosse là où elle se
trouvait il y avait des indices depuis
le début de la journée notamment que ses
médecins avaient émis un communiqué
disant qu'il était très inquiet pour
l'état de santé de la reine elizabeth 2
qui l'avait placé sous surveillance
médicale ses enfants ses petits enfants
avait même été appelés à son chevet et
donc il ya environ une heure et demie
sur le coup de 13h 13h30 le décès de la
reine elizabeth ii a été annoncé challes
devient immédiatement le roi
d'angleterre il portera selon ce que la
première ministre nous a dit le nom de
charles iii donc il accède au trône le
couronnement pourrait avoir lieu au
cours des prochaines semaines sinon des
prochains mois évidemment des
funérailles nationales seront organisées
sans aucun doute pour la reine elizabeth
ii décédé aujourd'hui voici d'ailleurs
un résumé de sa vie merci d'avoir été là
dans un instant céline galipeau vous
accompagne
elle n'était pas destinée à être reine
et pourtant elisabeth windsor devenu
elisabeth deux oreilles le plus long
règne de l'histoire né à londres le 21
avril 1926 elle était la troisième dans
l'ordre de succession après son nom et
son père une enfance qui semble plutôt
gai
à 13 ans elle rencontre le prince philip
de grèce et c'est le coup de foudre
lorsque la seconde guerre mondiale
éclate
elisabeth son rôle comme apprenti
conductrice d'ambulance et comme
mécanicienne
à 21 ans elle se révèle lors de son
discours à cape town en afrique du sud
où elle dédie sa vie à la monarchie
je déclare devant vous dit elle que je
me dévoue entièrement vouée à notre
grande famille impériale
sept mois plus tard elle épouse philippe
mangou baeten qui devra renoncer ses
titres royaux grecs et danois le mariage
aura duré 74 ans et ne prendra fin qu'à
la mort du prince en avril 2021
c'est en 1952 durant une visite
officielle au kenya que la princesse
apprend la mort de son père elle devient
alors reine mary ford à bastia
le couronnement est célébré à l'abbaye
de wesminster elizabeth n'a que 26 ans
et devient elizabeth 2
en moins de six mois la reine se rend
dans les caraïbes au moyen-orient en
afrique
elle verra l'éclatement de l'empiré
britannique
l'indépendance des anciennes colonies
qui deviennent est un membre du
commonwealth
dit qu'ils arbitrent a été son
secrétaire privé pendant douze ans
a sombré
à
son jubilé la reine réitère son serment
on se bat opposent made
in mice à la baisse même si ce serment
été prononcé il ya longtemps dit elle je
ne regrette rien je regrette
un dévouement à la vie publique certes
mais plutôt absente comme mère de
famille décriront plusieurs
très difficile d'être chefs d'état et
mère de famille sous d'indycar beacher
on lui reproche d'avoir été plus
préoccupés par les affaires de l'état
toute la famille
ce sont surtout les affaires familiales
qui font la une des journaux il y a eu
le mariage très royale de son fils le
prince charles avec lady diana en 1981
un véritable conte de fées où tout
semble réussir
aux deux fils william et harry mais
quelques années plus tard le couple se
sépare en 1996 c'est le divorce la
princesse hearn la seule fille de la
reine divorce également après avoir eu
ses deux enfants et le prince andrew se
séparent au site sa femme sarah ferguson
la monarchie devient de plus en plus
impopulaire la reine des cris 1992 comme
sa pire année ses deux fils se séparent
de leurs femmes et le château de windsor
et détruit par un incendie
58 eur en 1997 la mort tragique de la
princesse diana bouleverse tout le pays
la reine est absente elle est dans sa
résidence de balmoral avec son mari et
ses petits fils le public ne comprend
pas la popularité de la monarchie est à
son plus bas la reine seront alors à
londres et livre un discours en direct
diffusée sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision
les années passent et la reine
reconquiert le coeur des anglais elle
n'a plus à ses côtés sa mère la reine
mère et sa soeur la princesse margaret
le prince charles se remarie avec son
amour de jeunesse camilla parker bowles
la vie continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
son jubilé de diamant est célébrée sur
la tamise des millions de britanniques
le rendent hommage pour souligner ses 60
ans de règne
[Musique]
en egypte à saint-hilaire
la dignité et avec quelle nature
et ça c'est parfait pour
exécuter les rockets doit faire elle est
très réservé
dans les émotions est ça peut-être
est aussi bas avant avant trash tout son
temps pour dire qu'elle leur assurer une
continuité une stabilité malgré les
coups durs
en 2019 son fils cadet le prince à jo
doit faire face à la justice car il est
soupçonné d'agressions sexuelles sur une
mineure en janvier 2020 son petit fils
ali quitte la famille royale avec sa
femme megan à cause de la pression
médiatique et de l'ambiance anxiogène où
palais l'arène sous la devise anglaise
alors nous étions pas cette biographie
pour vous présenter la conférence de
presse juste
dix
pendant 70 ans
et
en voyant évoluer le canada vers cette
nation ambitieuse et diverses que nous
sommes aujourd'hui
à titre de son 12e premier canadien
j'ai du mal à croire que la dernière
rencontre jouée avec lui avec elle et
c'était ma dernière et je
m'en rappeler ces échanges vont manquer
elle était réfléchie sage curieuse et
dante drôle
vraiment tellement plus
dans un monde complexe
sa grâce sa détermination
ont pu nous réconforter
et nous donner la force le canada est
endeuillée
elle était une demie personnes préféré
au monde et elle va vraiment me manquer
c'est avec une grande tristesse
nous apprenons aujourd'hui
du décès de sa majesté la reine
elizabeth
du reste m elle était notre reine
pendant presque la moitié de l'existence
du canada et elle avait une affection
évidente est profonde pour tous les
canadiens
elle nous a servis avec force et courage
pendant soixante dix en
un an que nous sommes devenus le pays
ambitieux
optimiste diversifié
responsable
extraordinaire que nous sommes
aujourd'hui
en tant que ça 12e premier ministre
canadien
du beaucoup de mal à accepter que la
dernière fois que je les ai vus
sera la dernière fois
ces conversations vont me manquer
énormément
elle était
intéressée intéressante
engagé curieuse drôle
mais elle m'a beaucoup conseillé
beaucoup aidé
dans un monde très compliqué
sa présence sa graff
sa force
a été une ressource importante
pour nous tous
c'était une de mes personnes préféré au
monde
et elle me manquera énormément
le premier ministre du canada le premier
ministre du canada justin trudeau qui
fait l'éloge de la reine elizabeth 2 qui
est décédé au cours de la dernière heure
ça a été annoncé officiellement par
buckingham palace donc il décrit la
reine elizabeth 2 comme une femme ayant
servi avec force intelligence courage
elle était intéressée intéressante
engagé curieuse drôle le canada est en
deuil c'est ce que dit justin trudeau
c'était une de ces personnes préféré dit
le premier ministre quand même
particulier il est il et justin trudeau
le 12e premier ministre à avoir côtoyé
la reine elizabeth 2 dire que son règne
à la reine elizabeth ii a été très long
soixante dix ans de règne donc et
plusieurs premiers ministres qui se sont
succédé et qui ont établi une relation
avec elle de toute évidence justin
trudeau
peut-être parce que il l'a connue comme
le fils de pierre elliott trudeau
peut-être que ses premiers contacts avec
la reine elizabeth 2 sont survenus
lorsque son père pierre elliott était
premier ministre du canada peut-être
donc cette relation était un peu plus
profonde entre justin trudeau et la
reine elizabeth ii qu'avec d'autres
premiers ministres du pays donc les
drapeaux sont en berne si j'ai bien vu à
ottawa le drapeau sur la tour centrale
du parlement à ottawa a été mis en berne
et le canada est en deuil donc est la
suite du décès de la reine elizabeth ii
je vous rappelle que charles devient à
partir d'aujourd'hui le roi d'angleterre
il portera le titre de charles iii
évidemment il y aura des funérailles
nationales pour la haine elizabeth 2
pour
revoir en images mais aussi en sont la
vie la carrière le mandat de elizabeth
comme reine d'angleterre voici la
biographie présenté par préparé par la
collègue hazeb wade goris
elle n'était pas destinée à être reine
et pourtant elisabeth windsor devenu
elizabeth 2 aura eu le plus long règne
de l'histoire né à londres le 21 avril
1926 elle était la troisième dans
l'ordre de succession après son oncle et
son père une enfance qui semble plutôt
gai
à 13 ans elle rencontre le prince philip
de grèce et c'est le coup de foudre
lorsque la seconde guerre mondiale
éclate
elisabeth son rôle comme apprenti
conductrice d'ambulance et comme
mécanicienne
à 21 ans elle se révèle lors de son
discours à cape town en afrique du sud
où elle dédie sa vie à la monarchie
je déclare devant vous dit elle que je
me dévoue entièrement à vous et à notre
grande famille impériale
sept mois plus tard elle épouse philip
man battle qui devra renoncer ses titres
royaux grecs et danois le mariage aura
duré 74 ans et nous prendra fin qu'à la
mort du prince en avril 2021
c'est en 1952 durant une visite
officielle au kenya que la princesse
apprend la mort de son père elle devient
alors reine mary ford mme ashton
est toujours le fils saad khan
made in belgium locale
le couronnement est célébré à l'abbaye
de wesminster elizabeth n'a que 26 ans
et devient elizabeth 2
en moins de six mois la reine se rend
dans les caraïbes au moyen-orient en
afrique elle verra l'éclatement de
l'empiré britannique
l'indépendance des anciennes colonies
qui deviennent états membres du
commonwealth
10 qui arbitrera été son secrétaire
privé pendant douze ans
a sombré
à son jubilé la reine réitère son
serment rose va opposer made
in mice à la baisse même si ce serment
été prononcé il ya longtemps dit elle je
ne regrette rien je regrette leur traque
un dévouement à la vie publique certes
mais plutôt absente comme mère de
famille décriront plusieurs
très difficile d'être chefs d'état et
mère de famille sous l'indycar beacher
on lui reproche d'avoir été plus
préoccupés par les affaires de l'état
que de la famille
ce sont surtout les affaires familiales
qui font la une des journaux il y a eu
le mariage très royale de son fils le
prince charles avec lady diana en 1981
un véritable conte de fées où tout
semble réussir
aux deux fils william et harry mais
quelques années plus tard le couple se
sépare en 1996 c'est le divorce la
princesse terne la seule fille de la
reine divorce également après avoir eu
ses deux enfants et le prince andrew se
séparent au site sa femme sarah ferguson
la monarchie devient de plus en plus
impopulaire la reine des cris 1992 comme
sa pire année ses deux fils se séparent
de leurs femmes et le château de windsor
et détruit par un incendie
58 eur en 1997 la mort tragique de la
princesse diana bouleverse tout le pays
la reine est absente elle est dans sa
résidence de balmoral avec son mari et
ses petits fils le public ne comprend
pas la popularité de la monarchie est à
son plus bas la reine seront alors à
londres et livre un discours en direct
diffusée sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision
avec émotion
les années passent et la reine
reconquiert le coeur des anglais elle
n'a plus à ses côtés sa mère la reine
mère et sa soeur la princesse margaret
[Musique]
le prince charles se remarie avec son
amour de jeunesse camilla parker bowles
la vie continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
son jubilé de diamant est célébrée sur
la tamise 10 millions de britanniques le
rendent hommage pour souligner ses 60
ans de règne
[Musique]
la dignité
et avec elle
naturel
et ça c'est parfait pour
exécuter les rockets doit faire elle est
très réservé
dans les émissions est ça peut-être
est aussi bon en avant avant trash tout
son temps pour dire qu'elle leur assurer
une continuité une stabilité malgré les
coups durs
en 2019 son fils cadet le prince un
cloud doit faire face à la justice car
il est soupçonné d'agressions sexuelles
sur une mineure en janvier 2020 son
petit fils harry quitte la famille
royale avec sa femme mais guen à cause
de la pression médiatique et de
l'ambiance anxiogène au palais la reine
suit la devise anglaise à la lettre keep
calm and carry
[Musique]
mais son coup le plus dur sera
certainement la mort du prince philip le
9 avril 2021 quelques jours avant ses 95
ans
elle perd son compagnon de toujours son
confident ce sera une des dernières
photos officielles du couple à
la reine continuera à régner gardera
cette place particulière dans le coeur
des britanniques
car ils n'auront connu quelques hommes
york
ce sera un règne sur deux siècles et une
vie guidée par le devons
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames messieurs ici céline
galipeau alors oui on s'y attendait
quand même depuis quelques heures
puisque toute la famille royale était à
son chevet au château de balmoral donc
la nouvelle vous l'avez entendu la reine
elizabeth 2 s'est éteinte paisiblement à
l'âge de 96 ans après un très long règne
le plus long de l'histoire du royaume
uni soixante dix ans 7 mois et deux
jours c'est le palais de buckingham qui
en a fait l annonce par un tweet les
temps changent on le remarque à 13h30
heure de montréal très aimée très
respecté des britanniques et des pays et
dans les pays du commonwealth
elizabeth 2 sera donc demeurer fidèle à
son serment de servir ces sujets jusqu'à
la toute fin de sa vie puisqu'on l'a vu
il ya deux jours encore lors de la
passation des pouvoirs entre boris
johnson et les gosses elle était là elle
était souriante affaibli amaigri mais
quand même elle était elle semblait
assez en forme et donc à londres
évidemment c'est une nouvelle qui a qui
est qui qui a provoqué une immense
émotion beaucoup de britanniques sont
maintenant rassemblés devant le palais
de buckingham alors pendant qu'on voit
cette photo donc où on la voit vous
voyez très souriante avec la nouvelle
première ministre les strauss évidemment
cette photo avait suscité beaucoup de
commentaires parce qu'on voyait quand
même que sa main était bleu y est ce
qu'elle recevait des perfusions déjà
enfin on spéculait un petit peu mais
elle semblait quand même assez en forme
elle avait passé une heure avec le
premier ministre sortant boris johnson
donc elle était quand même assez bien à
ce moment là tout s'est accéléré par la
suite on va vous en parler maintenant le
deuil donc et déjà commencé à londres le
drapeau l'union jack est en berne sur le
palais de buckingham les gens se sont
rassemblés devant le palais comme lors
du décès de diana la bbc a joué l'hymne
national annonce du décès c'est donc un
processus de transition qui s'enclenche
charles est déjà devenu roi charles iii
dès la mort de sa mère
mais nous allons d'abord évidemment
revenir sur la vie de la reine longue
vie de service public qui avait commencé
avant son règne il avait servi notamment
lors de la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est le dernier chef d'état qui a peut
être connu cette période de 7 la grande
histoire
[Musique]
reykjavik yoro
chaud
[Musique]
j'ai envie de m'impliquer au tv
mon plus grand désir est que dans les
années à venir
[Musique]
et rester à vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça le double des coûts
il
qu'est ce qu'un
ce matin
[Musique]
speech spectacle
qu'est ce que c'est
mais jusqu'à de gamme en cause
ce pont
mon papa
[Musique]
élève du relais
longue life
parmi les morts
les
[Musique]
insurgés
une très longue vie un très long règne
70 ans dédié à au service à la monarchie
alors tout de suite vous présente nos
invités de spécialistes de passionnés de
la monarchie est celle bouthillier
analystes de la monarchie britannique et
marc laurendeau moi j'essaie bien
journaliste analyse de la monarchie
britannique lui aussi bonjour à vous
deux bonjour bonjour ouais je le disais
quand même c'est un peu une surprise on
savait qu'elle était affaibli on savait
qu'elle avait des problèmes de santé
mais il y a deux jours elle semblait
quand même assez en forme donc madame
boutiste les choses se sont accélérées
un sa santé s'est détériorée assez
rapidement oui comme vous l'avait dit
dès mardi en revue qui elle était encore
enfant il me semble grand sourire pour
accueillir la nouvelle première ministre
évidemment elle est appuyée sur sa canne
mais on sait aussi que l avais parlé
discuter une heure auparavant avec le
premier ministre sortant bob johnson est
aussi que suite à ces deux rencontres
elle avait travaillé aux fameuses boîtes
rouges là en soirée donc rien ne
laissait prévoir ce départ si rapide
mais bon on la sentait extrêmement
fragile de santé et leur bien ils ont
convoqué la famille aujourd'hui et on a
très bien compris dès ce matin lorsque
on ne sut que on demandait aux membres
de la famille de ceux de se rendre à
balmoral que là il y avait quelque chose
de spécial kyi qui se déroulait et ce
sont ses dc10 l'a fait mais j'espère
pour elle pour aussi les membres de la
famille qu'ils ont eu la chance de lui
dire un dernier au revoir oui on sait
assez peu de choses sur les
circonstances en tout cas de ce décès
marx et on s'est juste le communiqué dit
juste qu'elle l'est s'est éteinte
paisiblement entouré de ses proches nos
liens certain mystère qui entoure tout
ça et là donc c'est le même manque on a
retardé
un peu comme dans les régimes
soviétiques des fois on attendait 48
heures avant de donner aussi que
président de l'union soviétique ou
secrétaire général était décédé ça a été
le cas pour staline notamment mais c'est
pas pour les mêmes raisons je crois que
là un peu comme s'ils étaient dix
c'était pour permettre à la famille de
d'arriver sur place mais il est clair
quand on voyait de vaud évier devant les
grilles du palais ce matin on se disait
ces gens là savent des choses qu'on ne
sait pas avec visite même à la bbc mark
les commentateurs étaient déjà habillé
en noir vêtus de noir donc on sentait
dans leur ton que c'était beaucoup plus
sérieux que peut-être les alertes qu'on
avait eu auparavant sur la santé de la
reine mais c'est normal qu'à 96 1 on ait
des alertes mails étaient
particulièrement résistante et elle est
encore toute sa lucidité on ne mentionne
pas trouvé devant la situation céline ou
par exemple il refait lui tira la reine
vous souffrez par exemple de la maladie
d'alzheimer est ce que vous allez quand
même continuer à régner cela ne s'est
absolument pas posé là elle est restée
lucide à son devoir jusqu'à la fin parce
que c'est des horaires infernaux que
cela nous indique dans les derniers
moments là qu'elle s'est réfugiée à
balmoral parce que normalement elle sa
venue à londres assermentés la nouvelle
premier ministre c'était dans ses
habitudes comme on dit d'ouvrir les
boîtes rouges de se tenir au courant des
débats publics d'intervenir quand y
avait des cérémonies officielles je
pense qu'elle avait délégué charles pour
la dernière ouverture du parlement en
temps normal eli a l'air et porter la
couronne alors lieu elle était très
énergique et je le disais plus tôt elle
s'occupait de sa santé une personne qui
voyait ses médecins qui avaient eu des
habitudes saines qui faisaient du sport
l'équitation tant que ça a été possible
notamment est normalement ont répondu
décédé avant sa mère sa mère qui est
morte à 102 il ya un certain mystère
mais c'est le mystère de la ville
héridis t'explique pas tout elle a sans
doute ou une maladie qui l'a frappé à la
dernière minute mais on est sous le choc
parce que comme s'était dit dans le
reportage de vol des gazaouis vols de
gol 10 elle était sur deux siècles c'est
à dire que l rinié à partir du début des
années 50 jusqu'à maintenant 2022 c'est
quand même phénoménal et donc pour la
plupart des gens qui nous écoutent ils
n'ont connu qui lisabeth 2 et là on
plonge dans quelque chose de tout à fait
différent là c'est à dire comment va
être chaud est ce qu'il va être là
longtemps est-ce que ce retour ici tout
ça devient roi automatiquement à la mort
de sa mère et on a appris qu'il qu'il se
nomme ray charles iii et donc il sera
couronné un peu plus tard et de ça va
être officialisée dans les prochaines
heures mais il est déjà le nouveau roi
on voit tout de suite allé écouter le
premier ministre françois legault qui
commande donc le décès de la reine
elizabeth
condoléances à la famille royale
britannique et au peu
or depuis son couronnement en 1953 donc
elle a régné sur son pays pendant
presque 70 ans
c'était une femme qui avait le sens du
devoir public elle a soutenu son peuple
dans des moments qui était dieu est la
reine de a marqué les esprits par sa
force par son calme ou si elle était
pourtant aux premières loges des grands
événements du 20e siècle donc c'est un
grand personnage historique qui nous qui
est je demandais que le drapeau du
québec soit en berne sur tous les
édifices publics du gouvernement pour
souligner le décès de la reine elizabeth
ii
voilà c'était le premier ministre
françois legault dont qui commentait ce
décès il a parlé aussi lui aussi du sens
du devoir de cette femme qui avait très
jeune à 21 ans
10 ou dit à son peuple qu'elle dédiait
qu'elle allait dédié toute sa vie au
service de la monarchie je rejoins nos
invités madame beauty donc la reine
elizabeth 2 qui était très aimé des
britanniques et qui jusqu'à la fin et
donc on peut imaginer le choc
aujourd'hui je parlais de l'émotion
beaucoup de gens sont déjà réunis
rassemblés devant le palais de
buckingham et ils ont commencé à arriver
dès qu' on ne sut qu'elle avait que ses
problèmes de santé et sans savoir
exactement ce qui allait se passer mais
tout le monde sentait bien que l'heure
était grave et donc il y avait beaucoup
d'émotion on imagine oui les
britanniques quand on touche quand on
parle de leur famille royale c'est
extrêmement important pour eux pour bon
nombre d'entre eux
la reine elle fait partie de leur
famille donc pour plusieurs aujourd'hui
c'est c'est une grand mère qui les
quittent et je suis certain que la
grande grande majorité des britanniques
sont sous le choc évidemment parce que
ça c'est fait une version très rapide
quand on a vu les images de mardi
dernier mais il reste que il savait que
sa santé était extrêmement fragile et là
les gens vont se
rassembler comme dans les grands
événements qui touchent la famille
royale les gens sont portés à aller aux
grilles du palais de buckingham aussi
qu'elle n'est pas la cas l'état balmoral
mais même avant le moral je suis
convaincu qu'il ya des gens qui se
rassemblent déjà
autour des grilles pour rendre hommage
les c
des fleurs et les gens là vont chacun va
y aller du souvenir qu'ils en ont peu
importe l'événement que ce soit
évidemment il ya très peu de gens qui
peuvent raconter son couronnement 53
mais il y en a plusieurs qui se
souviennent des différents jubilé
d'argent d'or et de tout ce qui de tout
ce que les gens aiment et voir de la
reine lorsqu'elle allait rencontrer
différents groupes pour que ce soit dans
une résidence de personnes âgées dans un
habit tôt dans un hôpital elle était
toujours prête à discuter avec les gens
recevoir des bouquets de fleurs des
enfants donc et elle elle a vraiment
montré qu'elle voulait être proche des
gens dont elle était la souveraine et
c'est ça que les gens vont garder des se
souvenir qu'elle était
malgré tout jusqu'à un certain point
accessible et que les les gens vont
avoir beaucoup de peine dans les
prochaines semaines c'est certain que là
il ya toutes sortes
d'événements qui s'organise évidemment
il va avoir
fort probable une chapelle ardente les
funérailles dans quelques jours
évidemment par la suite il y aura dans
une banque elle j'imagine dans quelques
mois le couronnement du prince charles
du roi chaque événement pour s'habituer
faut s'habituer à le dire de cette façon
bon la première ministre a annoncé qu'
il porterait le titre de charles iii il
avait le choix de choisir un autre
prénom mais il a été il a décidé de
garder le sien donc là on a cette
information là dans quelques jours yaro
l' annonce officielle de l'accession au
trône habituellement ça se fait lors de
trois jours après et par la suite bis
alors
les événements vont s'enclencher mais on
en a pour une bonne dizaine de jours
avec tous ces préparatifs je convaincu
qu' il va avoir lorsque on a rapatrié le
corps de la reine à londres et que la
chapelle ardente vont commencer il va
avoir de très longues files de gens qui
vont vouloir lui rendent hommage et je
suis convaincu qu'ils ont déjà prévu là
un certain nombre de jours pour cet
événement là certainement parce qu'elle
était encore extrêmement populaire
c'était le personnage le plus populaire
c'était une femme certainement la plus
connue dans le monde mais marc y avait
un protocole qui avait été mise en place
elle de nombreuses années un protocole
en codes du décès de la reine donc ce
plan portait le nom de code london
bridge place d'armes le pont de londres
est tombé s'est effondré et tout est
prévu tout est prévu dix prochains jours
oui je serai c'est un fake mais là on a
dérogé un peu ensuite parce que ça n'est
pas d'essai qui survenu en pleine nuit
par surprise où on aurait fait là n'ont
souvent un certain rituel là on est dans
une autre situation où tout le monde l'a
prend en même temps et il est un peu
artificielle de droit proclamé la mort
d'elizabeth
avec la vitesse des médias en 2022 à peu
près tout le monde le sait maintenant ce
rituel est devenu inutile ce que j'ai
j'ai revu les différentes étapes de
l'opération london bridge céline est la
partie qui me paraît la plus importante
c'est la réunion du parlement il ya la
chapelle ardente comme disait madame
lebouthillier tout à l'heure mais il ya
aussi cette réunion du parlement on va
réunir les deux chambres pour constater
la fin du règne et qu'on passe un autre
règne alors ça ça va être une partie
importante le couronnement vont être
heureux on n'attendra pas un an comme on
l'avait fait pour elizabeth may le
couronnement lui va attendre que toute
cette période de deuil qu'on voit vivre
j'entendais tout à l'heure
pierre justin trudeau dire à quel point
tu est émotif c'est à sa prestation il
était attaché qu'il préférait dans le
monde oui oui drôle le conseillant même
c'est un jeune premier ministre c'est
intéressant de comparer l'attitude de
son père boit que j'ai connu à diverses
à divers chapitres et pierre trudeau
avait une ambiguïté vis-à-vis de la
reine il s'en servait constat bien
commode mais des fois de faire de
manière désinvolte une photo qui est
parue dans le journal ou pierre trudeau
derrière la reine en haut de l'escalier
fait une pirouette de canada anglais
l'uob beaucoup rapprochés ça mais quand
s'est agi de faire apposer sa
constitution de 1982 qui l'a invité pour
venir signer ça c'est elizabeth 2 et
s'est lui aussi avant qui lors des
olympiques de 1976 à montréal
alors pour certains premier ministre la
monarchie c'est très important ça a
l'air d'être beaucoup plus affectif que
cérébral de l'accueil du côté du fils de
rideau et stephen harper il
vous parler des premiers ministres mais
justement on va aller écouter un premier
ministre celui le l'ontario d'oxford qui
est en train de commenter le départ la
disparition de la reine elizabeth ii aux
moindres
vient de perdre le premier ministre
polonais viendra un petit peu plus tard
ya eu 24 jésus teint le voilà eh bien
c'était très court c'était une
déclaration assez courte donc on y
reviendra on essaiera de faire rejouer
cet extrait du premier ministre d'oxford
alors vous parlez du 1er mai marque qui
il ya eu des célébrations à tahoua
grandiose avec les unifoliés la reine et
toute la colline parlementaire à ottawa
était couverte de rouge je me souviens
pour avoir couvert ses événements
c'était une période de ferveur
monarchique
s'est littéralement fait prendre part ça
il a été un des premiers ministres qui a
appuyé ce système de de monarchie
parlementaire le plus fort d'autres ont
été plus distincts vis-à-vis ça n'avait
n'avait pas la même ferveur on a eu
toutes sortes de situations en réalité
12 premier ministre au canada une
douzaine et puis c'est une quinzaine en
grande-bretagne qui l'ont rencontré la
reine et puis elle était lucide je vous
le disais si cette personne l'avait
écrit un livre sur tout ce qu'elle sait
ce qu'elle savait maintenant suite été
phénoménal elle devait être d'une grande
sagesse il ya rencontré tous ces jeunes
à nos premiers ministres se grande
bretagne en particulier elle devait tout
savoir sur tout qu'elle lisait les
boîtes rouges une personne super informé
la et donc on aurait été bien curieux de
savoir ce qu'elle pensait tout ça mais
malheureusement la l'obligation de
réserve l'obligation de réserve oui lui
interdisait de dire ça on entrevues et
n'accorde jamais d'entrevue d'ailleurs
jamais jamais jamais quand ces faits
s'ils l'ont fait en particulier un doux
ça a été un désastre
charles à certaines occasions quand il
parlait à ses plantes ou six alors c'est
super yeux pour un monarque d'accepter
des entrevues jamais elle n'a accepté
d'être interviewé à la télévision
alors elle elle demeure avec toute sa
science avec toute son expérience
précieuse une personne est venue pour
nous les premiers ministres ont eu la
chance de la rencontrer et bénéficier de
ses conseils
[Musique]
notre notre ancienne correspondante
à londres à zeewolde le risque est
maintenant basé comme vous le savez à
washington mais qui a couvert pendant
des années la monarchie les frasques et
le reste hazeb donc un grand choc
aujourd'hui avec sa disparition ben on
pouvait le voir vous savez les
commentateurs sur bbc il avait vraiment
les sanglots dans la voix quand ils ont
annoncé le décès de la reine tout le
monde s'y attendait mais tout le monde
redoutait un peu ce moment chez les
britanniques ce qui va être intéressant
comme le soulignait un marx et quel
genre de roi va être le prince charles
parce que opposé ici aussi on si on le
compare à la reine la reine comme marc
viennent le dire n'a jamais accordé
d'entrevue alors que le prince charles a
toujours dit un peu ce qu'ils pensent et
on connaît à ses idées sur l'
architecture sur l'environnement
aliments bio donc c'est quelqu'un qui
n'a pas qui n'a pas autant de réserves
que la reine donc ça va être intéressant
de voir quel genre de roi et va être et
puis il accepte même au trône à 72 ans
c'est quand même assez tard le prince
william qui est le maintenant le
l'héritier de la couronne après le
prince charles à 40 ans donc la reine 70
ans de règne je pense qu'on ne connaîtra
pas ça très très souvent mais c'est une
journée extrêmement un bouleversant pour
les britanniques parce qu'elle a
toujours été là elle a toujours été dans
leur vie et ce qui est assez incroyable
céline c'est qu'il ya deux jours elle
rencontre est la première ministre la
nouvelle première ministre dé strauss
deux jours avant sa mort quand même donc
elle a été vraiment elle a respecté son
devoir jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la fin et
là elle a rendu l'âme aujourd'hui mais
je pense que les britanniques ont tenu à
remercier toutes toutes ces années de
dévouement qu'elle leur a accordé lors
de son jubilé cet été au mois de juin
ils étaient tous là pour lui dire merci
parce qu'ils savaient bien que le moment
est l'arrivée où elle ne sera plus là et
vous voulez vraiment la célébrer durant
son vivant et ils l'ont fait on a vu
apparaître deux fois sur le bac au
balcon de buckingham où bon les
britanniques étaient très heureux de
l'avoir mais déjà ce moment là elle
n'apparaissait pas très souvent elle
voyait pas beaucoup ça fait plusieurs
mois qu'elle a des problèmes de mobilité
physique donc on n'a pas non plus livré
le dit elle était très affaiblie
depuis le décès de son mari un depuis le
principe depuis la mort du prince
philippe absolument céline 18 mois sans
le prince philip qui était vraiment son
rock ils étaient plus de 70 ans mariée
elle a rencontré à l'âge de 13 ans ils
ont eu quatre enfants donc lui était
vraiment son rock et pis c'est lui aussi
qui s'occupait des affaires de la maison
parce que la reine était chef d'état le
voyager beaucoup et les experts beaucoup
de ses biographes disait elle a eu un
parcours sans faute en tant qu rennes en
tant que mère de famille elle a été
plutôt absente le prince charles en a
souffert les ses deux fils sa fille la
princesse anne et les seuls moments où
on voyait la reine extrêmement joyeuse
et souvent c'est ce que les gens ces
observateurs disent et quand elle voyait
les chevaux les courses de chevaux ou
encore avec ses chiens les colis qui lie
à eux doivent connaître ses plus grand
secret mais la reine a toujours gardé
cette espèce de réserve et les seules
fois où elle pouvait se révéler un petit
peu c'est lors de ces de ses discours ou
lors de son fameux discours à chaque
année quand elles le souhaitent ses
voeux aux britanniques est la dernière
fois durant la pandémie elle a tenu à
les rassurer en disant qu'ils vont y
arriver ils vont passer à travers donc
elle a toujours gardé cette espèce de
rôle de grand-mère en chef mais aussi de
présence qui a toujours été là d'une
présence rassurante pour les
britanniques qui soit royalistes ou pas
qui soit de gauche de droite elle a
toujours été là et là les britanniques
devront s'habituer à son absence oui
merci azem on vous retrouve un petit peu
plus tard on voit tout de suite allé à
londres rejoindre
collaboratrice mary boyd a qui est sur
place je crois qu'elle est
bonsoir à vous madame mode
alors parlez moi un peu de l'état
d'esprit après l annonce de cette
nouvelle qui a dû attristé beaucoup de
gens
oui en effet c'est vraiment une nouvelle
extrêmement triste et un coot un coup de
tonnerre c'est du jamais vu ça y est
certaines rues sont moins complètement
vide de volant à l'endroit où je me
trouve par exemple c'est vraiment très
ville de jeu voyait un habitant dans le
monde me dire qu'il rend très vite chez
lui pour allumer sa télé et regarder les
informations regardez les archives sur
l'arène et pendant ce temps à buckingham
en revanche la foule la foule ne fait
que grossir devant les grilles du
château malgré la pluie
malgré la nuit qui vient de tomber il ya
vraiment de plus en plus de monde et
pourtant ce n'était pas une si grande
surprise jusqu'au la reine avait déjà
quand même 96 ans on savait que sa santé
décliner ça faisait un nom qu'elle
réduisait ses déplacements en public
voir quels les annuler complètement mais
quand même un britannique me disais tout
à l'heure qu'il ne pouvait pas y croire
elles et leurs liens avec le passé
puisqu'elle a connu quand même que nos
ministres sont premiers listen churchill
ce ne sera me disait-il plus jamais
comme avant et donc aujourd'hui c'est
donc son fils charles iii qui prend sa
succession oui et parlez nous un peu du
protocole de ce qui s'en vient comment
comment ça va être organisée dans les
prochains jours
alors va ya voir ça va durer dix jours
vous que les funérailles commencent
est-ce que vous m'entendez oui on vous
entend encore ça a coûté pardon avant
que le souvenir hague commence le
cercueil de la reine devrait être
déplacée puisque dans la capitale
puisque elle est décédée dans sa
résidence à balmoral en écosse louche le
train le nouveau
plus le prince charles est le nouveau
roi donc charles iii devrait aussi
rencontrer la nouvelle première ministre
liste run il va y avoir aussi des séries
body dans la cathédrale saint paul la
population devrait pouvoir se recueillir
sur le cercueil de la reine et marie
qu'est ce que les britanniques vont
surtout retenir du règne d'elizabeth ii
mais c'est vraiment comme vous avez dû
me dire déjà un peu là la grand mère de
la nation tout le monde m il ya eu plein
de
problèmes avec la famille royale qui a
été très souvent critiqués dernièrement
il a entendu avec le prince andrew le
fils de la reine mais là elle n'a jamais
et vous critiquer quoi qu'il arrive tout
le monde la dore on a fêté ses 70 ans de
règne il ya quelques mois en juin
dernier c'était quatre jours de
festivités incroyable tout le monde
était réuni dans la capitale et dans les
autres villes du pays donc on retiendra
une femme qui faisait le lien entre tout
le monde qu'on était un peu le ciment de
la nation
[Musique]
il faut rappeler aussi que tout ça on va
découvrir un peu comment ça va se passer
parce que l'année dernière funérailles
d'un roi c'était il ya cinq il ya plus
d'un demi-siècle quoi donc tout ça à
voir dans les prochains jours merci
beaucoup marie de ce témoignage
alors beaucoup de réactions déjà louis
blouin vous êtes à ottawa beaucoup de
réactions on a entendu monsieur trudeau
un peu plus tôt ouais absolument qui a
dit que le canada céline il est en deuil
suite rues d'auch qui a souligné qu'il
était le 12e premier ministre de la
reine elizabeth ii c'est dire
l'importance qu'elle a eu dans
l'histoire canadienne il a souligné le
fait qu'elle a accompagné cette histoire
on fait le des anglais était là aussi
dans des moments marquants on se
souviendra par exemple lors de la
cérémonie de signature là au moment du
rapatriement de la constitution
canadienne c'était en 1982 sur trudeau
l'a décrite comme étant engagé intéressé
curieuse du rôle il à paris de toucher
ou si monsieur trudeau il a même versé
une larme selon ge com 10 convient elle
si difficile d'accepter que la dernière
rencontre que j'ai eue avec elle c'était
bel et bien la dernière on peut entendre
si vous voulez une partie du discours de
monsieur trudeau un peu plus tôt dans un
monde très compliqué
sa présence sa graff
sa force
a été une ressource importante
pour nous tous
c'était une de mes personnes préféré au
monde
et elle me manquera énormément
les actions d'autres chefs de partis
aussi céline il ya le chef du bloc
québécois notamment qui a réagi on se
demander quelle forme ça allait prendre
il dit notamment elle aura été au coeur
d'un siècle troubles avec le désir d'y
être une force positive
je vous signale aussi la réaction du
chef du npd jack meeting est dit la
reine elizabeth ii a vécu une vie une
vie d'histoire et de devoir était aussi
une mère une grand mère une arrière
grand mère mes pensées vont aujourd'hui
à sa famille qui a perdu un véritable
pilier dans leur vie et pour entendre
députés de l'opposition officielle chez
les conservateurs je vous invite à
écouter luc berthold
c'est une dame qui a traversé toutes
sortes d'épreuves toutes sortes de
crises que vu la société changé au fil
des années qui a toujours été la guitare
avec beaucoup de grâce et beaucoup de
prestance donc c'est une grande dame qui
a marqué la vie de nombreux canadiens
mais aussi de nombreux britanniques et
de nombreux citoyens partout dans le
monde qui nous a quittés aujourd'hui
et ici au canada céline ya tout un
protocole qui se met en place vous voyez
derrière moi il ya le tour de haut sur
la tour de la paix le drapeau qui était
en berne et six dans la cité
parlementaire ce sera le cas pour tous
les édifices fédéraux il faut comprendre
que à partir du décès de la reine ben là
c'est maintenant charles qui est le chef
de l'état canadien il ya des étapes qui
doivent survenir notamment la
gouverneure générale qui doit rappeler
le cabinet pour proclamer un nouveau
règne bureau du conseil privé doit se
rassembler pour procréer proclame un
nouveau monarque est en théorie le
premier ministre devrait rappeler les
députés pour déposer une motion seconde
et par l'opposition pour déclarer
loyauté et condoléances du parlement au
nouveau roi quand ce sera fait
précisément c'est pas clair pour le
moment mais vous voyez que recruteur
protocole qui est assez défini la au
quart de tour pour la suite des choses
le juge de la cour suprême premier
ministre vont devoir prêter serment
d'allégeance aussi au nouveau monarque
il va falloir changer la nomenclature de
toutes sortes de documents du
gouvernement fédéral qui contiennent les
mots rentes pour que ça devienne le
mauroy spécifiquement alors c'est très
très basse que ce qui va se passer on
verra aussi pour une réaction possible
de la gouvernance générale oui on
entendait donc premier ministre trudeau
vous disait assez émotif qui disait que
c'est une de ces personnes préféré dans
le monde qu'elle avait vu manquer mais
la reine avait aussi un attachement à
ces particuliers avec le canada elle a
beaucoup beaucoup voyagé dans le monde
mais c'est au canada qu'elle est venue
le plus souvent à la faye 24 visiteurs
22 visite officielle 22 visés et et puis
elle disait souvent que quand elle
venait au canada bain se sentait à la
maison des mots qu'a répété aussi le
charme quand il était là il ya encore
quelques semaines à peine au courant de
l'été alors attachement particulier de
nombreuses présences je pense la
dernière visite non officielle c'est en
2015 dernière visite officielle c'était
en 2010 très bien merci louis à plus
tard surpris ils nous retrouvons
maintenant hazeb donc parce que beaucoup
de réactions dans le monde évidemment on
imagine à la rencontre est tellement de
chefs d'état elle s'est promenée dans
tellement de pays elle était aussi à la
tête du komo noël
absolument céline écouté plusieurs chefs
d'état en parle de quatorze présidents
15 premier ministre également une
douzaine de premiers ministres canadiens
15 premier ministre britannique elle a
aussi rencontré beaucoup de célébrités
on savait marilyn monroe lé lady gaga
dwight eisenhower l'ancien président des
états unis donc c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours été présent donc aujourd'hui
tout le monde tient à saluer son son
travail son règne alors ici aux etats
unis joe biden a dit qu'elle était d'une
dignité incomparable même dans notre
champ pas tweeté en disant que lui et
mélanie frais leurs condoléances à toute
la famille royale qu'il n'y avait
personne comme elle georges bush a lancé
un président des états unis george w
bush a également salué tout le règne de
la reine à quel point c'était une
personne incroyable
incomparable qui a régné pendant 70 ans
donc tout le monde a tenu vraiment à
souligner son son règne il faut aussi
souligner quelque chose ces lignes c'est
que la reine elle est aussi la grand
mère du prince william et harry mais
depuis que la princesse diana est
décédée elle jouait aussi un peu le rôle
de leur mère vous savez la princesse
diana décédée quand le prince william
avait 15 ans donc depuis ce temps là
c'est un peu elle qui a pris ce rôle là
envers ses petits-enfants donc
certainement qu'aujourd'hui ses deux
petits fils doivent aussi ressentir 7 7
12 alors si vous voulez même si bon il
était bien conscient qu'elle avait 96
ans elle avait une relation toute
particulière avec avec eux
particulièrement ses deux petits-fils
tas parce que justement elle joue un peu
le rôle de grand-mère mais de mer un
petit peu de donc pour eux ça va être
très difficile on connaît sa très grande
complicité avec le prince harry et qui
maintenant ils habitent aux états unis
mais on sent vraiment qu'il y avait une
complicité entre lui et sa grand mère
ainsi que le prince william dont
particulièrement pour les pour les deux
pour les deux frères ça va être une
journée assez difficile aujourd'hui sur
sa lancée avec harry les relations
étaient plus compliquées avec la reine
ces derniers temps bah c'est à dire
qu'on ne saura jamais vraiment ce qui se
passe derrière les coulisses dans les
coulisses le prince harry est partie il
a donné une entrevue à oprah ça c'était
extrêmement mal vu par les britanniques
quand on était là-bas lors du jubilé
quand il est venu justement à la
cathédrale saint paul les gens n'étaient
pas contents qu'il soit là ils ont
écouté des décidé de ne plus faire
partie de la de la royauté en tout cas
de ne plus servir la royauté mais
évidemment il sera toujours le petit
fils de la reine mais pourquoi est il là
aujourd'hui pour souligner son règne
donc les britanniques n'étaient pas
contents parce qu'il a critiqué le
prince charles il a critiqué aussi son
frère qui avait un peu un certain froid
que le prince charles ne donnait plus
d'argent au prince terry il a délivré
cette entrevue aux américains à oprah
winfrey donc ça a été extrêmement mal vu
par les britanniques surtout par les
royalistes mais ce ce qu'il a toujours
dit c'est qu'il garde une relation
extrêmement extrêmement bonnes avec la
reine il a toujours gardé cette relation
là pardon avec la reine est là elle a
quand même réussi
malgré tout à avoir une famille très
soudée autour d'elle aujourd'hui ils
sont tous à son chevet le prince charles
vient aussi de dire comment il est
extrêmement attristé par la mort de sa
mère ce qui est assez incroyable c'est
qu'il devient roi qui en même temps il
perd sa mère quand même donc s'il ya
quelque chose d'assez de pas très
évident là dedans et la reine d'ailleurs
en avait parlé lorsqu'elle avait perdu
son père elle est encore très jeune à
l'ailé 25 ans et là tout de suite elle
est devenue reine elle accéder il ya eu
son couronnement un an plus tard en juin
1953 mais elle disait qu'en fait c'était
une période difficile parce qu'elle
perdait son père avec à qui elle est
extrêmement proche mais en même temps a
prêté serment comme rennes à la
monarchie elle devenait rennes donc
c'était toute une toute une étape donc
c'est comme si elle n'avait pas vraiment
le temps de faire le deuil de son père
et c'est certainement ce qui risque
d'arriver pour le prince charles il
devient roi c'est le roi charles iii il
va falloir aussi qu'il faille fasse le
deuil de sa mère
très bien merci beaucoup à z je vous en
prie alors on retrouve nos deux palets
nice mena mme lebouthillier et marc
laurendeau on parle des relations entre
la grand mère et ses petits fils
d'ailleurs le prince harry était à
londres avec son épouse meggen et donc
il a pu se rendre lui aussi au chevet de
sa grand mère on sait qu'ils vivent
maintenant aux états unis madame
lebouthillier donc
on se souviendra quand même de cette
femme qui a été un pilier une
institution qui est resté toujours très
digne malgré tous les problèmes qui a pu
y avoir dans la famille se sait quelque
chose dont on a beaucoup beaucoup parlé
ces dernières années quand même oui et
c'est ce qu'on va garder comme souvenir
c'est que elle a toujours paru
extrêmement calme devant les les hauts
et les bas de la famille et on a
toujours senti qu'elle cherchait à
trouver le moyen
d'apaiser les esprits de de trouver une
solution au problème et
par la suite bien c'est certain que
chacun ont été dans le sens qu'ils
voulaient mais on sent très bien que l
et es quelqu'un chez qui les enfants les
petits-enfants pouvait halliche et
demander conseil
essayez de voir son prouve répondent
ensemble une solution mais vous savez
quand une famille vit autant sur la
place publique devant tout le monde
c'est extrêmement difficile de
garder
savez votre vie intime vous en avez pas
vous vous êtes devant vous êtes comme le
poisson rouge notre bakel où tout le
monde vous voit et le moindres faits et
gestes sont analysés à l heure regarder
à gauche donc ça ça veut dire tel ou tel
événement non leur regarda droit donc il
faut identifier ça comme un autre sujet
donc c'est mais la reine toujours et le
su garder le cap et elle n'a jamais
donné d'entrevue c'est vrai mais il ya
eu six occasions
tout au long de son règne où elle prit
la parole qu'elle s'est intéressée à son
club pour vraiment donner
une certaine opinion ce n'était pas un
entrevue mais on l'a vu la dernière fois
ça a été lors de
du début de la pandémie est
évidemment les message de noël à noël
que tout le monde suivait la au même si
c'était seulement quelques minutes à
chaque année les familles hyardet tout
arrêter les festivités s'assoyait devant
leur poste de télévision et écouter le
discours de la reine et chacun
apprécié parce que cette fois à chaque
fois elle faisait comme une sorte de
résumé de l'année et des projets qui
s'annonçait donc le souvenir va être
très très fort les gens vont soir vous
regardez là surtout
l'idée du devoir accompli
tel qu'elle l'avait mentionné lors de ce
cours de ses 18 ans en afrique du sud
oui ils marquent elle a vraiment diriger
la monarchie dans une période de
profonds bouleversements c'est sûr sur
soixante dix ans et s'est passé
énormément de choses
la modernisation de lyon souvient va je
sais pas à la lune il ya tellement
d'événements qui se sont produits sous
son règne est elle en quelque sorte
modernise et non la monarchie pourtant
que diana aurait pu le faire ou
peut-être le william un jour sera appelé
à le faire mais parce que c'est une
reine traditionnelle et conservatrice
mais ça a été quand même une grande
communicatrice sur m'explique
sa lointaine prédécesseur la reine
victoria à la fin de sa vie était une
recrue on la voyait pas elle rencontrait
pas les six sujets comme ils disent à
bête les a rencontrés d'abord vous
souvenez elle s'habillait toujours de
croyez de couleurs voyantes vos
complices l'apercevoir dans la foule
elle s'est raidi mais avec des gants
certes mais elle s'est raidi mais elles
faisaient de ce qu'on n'a pas le droit
kaba août elle faisait des espèces de
mêlée où elle rencontrait la foulée
parler aux gens de façon très familière
à la il n'a elle a innové de ce côté là
et puis nous pardonne moi
elle dû s'adapter c'est la relation avec
la presse c'est à dire que
l'expression maison de verre est employé
tout à l'heure ce nouveauté c'est à dire
que la royauté bénéficie beaucoup de du
mystère du fait qu'on les connaît pas
tout à fait alors bénéficier un peu de
ça mais avec la presse
la presse à potins faut pas l'appeler
autrement la presse de londres qui est
très vite et qui court après diana l'a
littéralement avec des paparazzi une
presse très avide de patin sur la
monarchie mais que dans la beaucoup
souffert dernièrement la reine dû
composer avec ça on dit que la
familiarité engendre le mépris et donc
la monarchie aux puces ou ferait
souffrir dis-je de ce manque d'intimité
de 2,2 de distance de mystère mais elle
a bien composer avec ça ce que l'on
servait d'elle était toujours positif
tandis que ce qu'on apprenait sur les
autres membres de la famille faisait un
peu
casser la coquille si j'ose dire et on
enlevait du vernis et on se dit oh ils
sont comme ça ils sont finalement ils
sont pour mieux que nous alors il
fallait passer cette épreuve c'est très
difficile pour une institution aussi
mystérieuse et arte disons que la
monarchie de traverser l'existence d'une
presse qui est à vos côtés consommables
qui vous qui vous photographier sur la
rue kiki note vos faits et gestes
elle n'accorde pas d'entrevue mais je
vous dise est une bonne communicatrice
j'ai vu un documentaire dernièrement qui
a été diffusé où on la voit alors sa
couronne elle dit cetrel où j'ai de la
misère à porter ça alors il dit l'âme
elle dit quand j'ai discours là j'ai
obligé de maintenir la tête droite parce
que si je me penche comme casser le cou
littéralement l expliquer ça et c'était
fabuleux là une façon un peu
humoristique d'ailleurs la reine on le
disait c'est monsieur trudeau qui le
disait elle a beaucoup d'humour à la sas
est une de ses qualités la fameuse
phrase sur l'annus horribilis 1 est un
exemple de ça elle avait un espèce
d'humour très retenue et qui passait
bien la rampe alors elle a su s'adapter
à son siècle moi je trouve ça en étant
conservatrice la ccpo une monarque
flamboyant qui veut innover comme
peut-être charles beer aux bouquetins
sans doute vouloir innover et changer la
monarchie entend thèse c'est pas très
chanceux de s'appeler charles de 3,6
vous souvenez de l'histoire le premier
chat aurait été exécuté
c'est un choix
ben oui il ya décidé de garder sur un an
mais il aurait pu prendre une
prénom qui a une que passer plus
glorieux ciao choisir entre parenthèses
ça a été un peu mieux mais
alors oui
l'isis et président fondateur sa manière
qu'on va retenir de ce long règne
d'elizabeth deux et on va commencer avec
le commonwealth puisque c'est une
organisation d'anciennes colonies
britanniques de pays ayant des liens
historiques et linguistiques avec
londres on en a beaucoup parlé le canada
en fait partie et sous son règne le
commonwealth s'était enduit compte
aujourd'hui 54 pays contre seulement 9
lors de l'arrivée d'elizabeth ii sur le
trône sophie langlois qui nous en parle
[Musique]
l'état est cuit durant cette visite au
kenya le père d'elizabeth le roi georges
6 meur
[Musique]
propulsant la jeune princesse sur le
trône à l'âge de 25 ans ce voyage en
afrique sera marquant
tôt
la reine gardera une affection
particulière pour le kenya qu'elle
visitera trois fois à cette époque une
douzaine de nations africaines sont
encore des colonies britanniques
les années 1950 des années 1960 sont des
années où la question de l'afrique être
une priorité elle est au coeur de
l'actualité donc est-ce que c'est par
affection ou c'est pour défendre des
intérêts stratégiques importants peu
importe le résultat et l'or
quand elizabeth ii est couronné l'empiré
britannique est déjà pratiquement rayé
de la carte
durant la première moitié du 20e siècle
le royaume uni la salle et hooper la
plupart de ces colonies dont l'aisne en
1947 dans la mesure où certains états
notamment l'inde choisissent de devenir
d'épouser la forme républicaine mais
elle comme un noël s'effrite dans une
certaine mesure parce que soudainement
la communauté d'intérêts est moins
intense
en 1953 le cominois n'a que 4 ans
d'existence et ses pays membres la jeune
reine doit opérer une transition
délicate transformer l'ancien empire
colonial en regroupant libre de pays
souverains
australia and in flames of hand in hand
of frog
début de son règne sa majesté prend
l'habitude de visiter régulièrement les
étapes son royaume en 1953 et 54 elle
fait une tournée de six mois dans une
dizaine de pays
[Musique]
75% des australiens traite à l'évent la
reine sur son parcours
mais ça reste un rôle symbolique les
symboles sont puissants et c'est clair
que lorsqu'on occupe des fonctions qui
sont pas politiquement déterminante on
peut quand même par des gestes par des
façons de manifester de l'intérieur
endroits de certaines choses avoir une
certaine influence
elizabeth ii se donne comme mission
d'utiliser toute la puissance du symbole
royal pour préserver les liens
économiques et politiques entre le
royaume uni et ses anciennes colonies
dans les années 60 elle déploie
plusieurs opération charme en afrique
pour convaincre les nouvelles nations
indépendantes de se joindre aux comme un
noir
en
[Musique]
1961 le ghana est indépendant depuis
quatre ans le président and chrome a
commencé à emprisonner ses opposants à
se rapprocher du bloc soviétique et
menace de se retirer du commonwealth le
premier ministre britannique jugent
qu'un voyage royal trop risqué mais la
reine ciron quand même
chose est vraie c'était sûr aimant la
visite royale la plus controversée de
l'histoire dit le journaliste de bbc la
reine à 11 jours pour convaincre un
chrono de ce rallye au commonwealth
sa majesté n'hésite pas à parler de
longues heures sous un soleil ardent aux
côtés du président controversé et même à
danser avec lui
[Musique]
isabel ii est accueilli comme une vraie
star presque partout où elle débarque
comme ici à new delhi 2 millions
d'indiens accueille le convoi royal
pendant soixante ans elle va profiter de
cette affection du public pour
consolider le comme noir le faire
grandir
comme on peut le voir sur les photos de
famille le sommet plus récent où le
prince charles est désormais éviter
comme futur chef du commonwealth de se
payer en 1953 l'organisation regroupe
aujourd'hui 54 états membres la reine
était toujours là chef d'état de 15 de
ces pays qu'on nomme les royaumes du
commonwealth le canada en fait partie
[Musique]
cinq
mille ans
dans les quinze états qui reste il y
aura
dans la prochaine succession sera
hautement importante parce que chaque
état aura un peu à se remettre en
question ça posera inévitablement la
question on m'arrête où on continue le
décès d'elizabeth 2 pour et il a mené le
canada à abolir la monarchie
notre constitution très difficile à
modifier sera t'elle un obstacle si on
se limitait à un ordre du jour qui ne
portait que sur la monarchie et qu'une
réforme à coût nul au fond on
conserverait un chef d'état un
gouverneur qui aurait peu de pouvoir
mais qui jouerait au fond le rôle
nécessaire qui est le sien dans le
système parlementaire je pense qu'un
consensus serait possible
parce que l'attachement envers la reine
disparaîtra avec elle et que le prêt
charles beaucoup moins populaire les
abolitionnistes pourrait réussir à
rallier une majorité de citoyens et de
politiciens à l'idée de ne plus avoir
droit comme chef d'état
ce sont deux grandes questions qu'on
pose quel avenir pour la monarchie au
canada notamment marc
ya certaines attaches main mais il n'est
visiblement il va y avoir des remises en
question périodiques que j'entendais les
gens du bloc qui était très très
empathique face au désir face au décès
de la reine mais il reste qu' il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui voudraient un
autre symbole pour continuer sur la
lancée de ce juriste qui prenait la
parole dans le reportage on voudrait
maintenant effectivement que papa tu te
fais un régime présidentiel mais
quelqu'un qui accomplit et fonctions
protocolaires et évidemment qu'ils
respectent l'obligation de réserve qui
ne se prononce pas sur les questions
politiques et à côté de lui un premier
ministre élu c'est presque un régime
présidentiel presque mais je sais pas si
nos compatriotes anglophones ça déjà été
à ses yeux
pour être convaincu de ça et puis très
important et que pas eu le temps de
souligner ce juriste c'est que toute
construction les verrouiller c'est à
dire depuis que l a été repassés par
revu par pierre trudeau le père c'est
pratiquement impossible il faut le
consentement des deux chambres il faut
le consentement des dix provinces ça
peut arriver on veut pas abolir la
monarchie parce que il toujours avoir
une tu vas s'objecter alors c'est
malheureusement malheureusement je le
dis bien un peu rêver en couleurs c'eût
été possible en australie on fait un
référendum et là le premier ministre
déclencher un référendum a perdu le
pouvoir et ce tonneau qui lui a succédé
tu as rangé la question de manière à ce
qu'elle soit ambigu je résume et que les
gens ne votent pas oui pour l'abolition
de la monarchie parce qu'il y avait un
fort vent
vers l'abolition de la monarchie en
australie et ça a été la réforme a été
comme court circuiter de cette manière
là je n'ai plus d'espoir rené lévesque
qui pourtant
comment dirais-je aurait eu de bonnes
raisons de s'objecter à la monarchie on
n'a jamais mené ce combat
là la reine était vivante c'était
peut-être pas une question se posait
tellement tout le monde se disait c'est
quelque chose qu'on va repousser plus
tard mais mais mme lebouthillier le fait
que charles sont peut-être moins
populaire que sa mère est ce que là
c'est peut-être là que les questions
vont se poser peut-être pas dans
l'immédiat mais peut-être dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années
mais c'est certain qu'il va avoir un
questionnement qui va se faire mais
comme marc viens de le dire
changer la constitution pour ceux à
bouira monarchie c'est presque
impossible il ya tellement ça a été
verrouillé dans la constitution en 82 et
et comme si il ya peu plus de chance que
ça se fasse mais il reste qu'avec le bon
on dit que la pop que le prince charles
est pas aussi populaire que sama bon ça
c'est certain que le roi charles va
devoir faire ses preuves il va devoir on
sait certaines ses prises de position
sur un certain nombre de sujets mais je
crois aussi que depuis les deux
dernières années ou moins la dernière
année et demie ou leur remplacer sa mère
dans plusieurs fonctions on a vu que ça
se faisait en douceur qu'il y avait une
transition qui qui était en marche et
moi je dois dire que faudrait laisser la
chance au coureur de faire ses preuves
de dire ce que lui veut comme ça c'est
certain qu'il va avoir des changements
ça
on peut pas se le cacher il va en avoir
il va en avoir de nombreux changements
mais il reste que la reine est en partie
on va modifier le prix le roi charles va
devoir
dire faire montrer ses points d'intérêt
et pour le commonwealth eh bien tant
qu'à moi j'ai bien l'impression que
les soutiens comme tel votre devoir
soto analyser et trouver des solutions
de rechange est-ce que c'est l'abolition
complète
est ce que c'est la modification
là aussi il va avoir beaucoup de
réflexions et les prochaines années vont
nous montrer qu' on se penche sur le
sujet il encore on essaiera de trouver
la meilleure solution possible pour
satisfaire le plus grand nombre c'est
certain qu'il va toujours avoir des gens
qui vont être content les décisions qui
vont être prises mais je crois que le
prêt le roi charles et le prince william
aussi il veut que
cette action-là le commonwealth soit
modifié de quelle façon ça reste à voir
voilà on voit des images de la reine
mais vous voyez aussi ces images de ces
gens qui viennent déposer un bouquet de
fleurs devant le palais de buckingham ça
nous rappelle un peu comment ça s'était
passé à la mort de diana il y avait eu
un effet de la même façon beaucoup de
dommages à la princesse cette fois c'est
pour la reine elizabeth 2 alors on me
dit qu'on va joindre azeb wolde giorgis
à washington donc hazeb
lorsque madame routiers vous venez de
dire vous savez les défis sont énormes
là pour le nouveau roi charles il ya le
break site l'ecosse qui menacent d'avoir
son indépendance mais aussi l'irlande du
nord qui veut se réunifier avec
l'irlande donc la reine finalement l
heure a eu 70 ans de règne sans faute un
parcours sans faute mais on est en train
de voir peut-être l'éclatement du
royaume uni avec ses deux ces deux
régions là qui pourrait quitter
l'angleterre si vous voulez donc là il
va falloir jusqu'à présent elle avait
cette image ou lll réunifiée si vous
voulez les britanniques le peuple
britannique la reine tout le monde se
reconnaît en la reine j'avais été en
écosse et les gens disent eh ben on aime
notre haine dont il y avait encore cette
espèce de d'attachement la monarchie est
ce que le prince charles lui va réussir
à avoir que que les écossais ou même les
irlandais et ce même attachement que la
reine a eu ça va être un très très grand
défi pour lui également la famille
royale on l'a souligné tout à l'heure le
prince andrew qui a accordé cette
fameuse entrevue à bbc où justement il
est accusé de pédophilie et d'avoir été
très proche d'eux jeffrey obstine donc
déjà là on n'aimait pas trop ça dans la
famille royale le prince harry qui est
parti meghan markle qui a parlé d'un
climat anxiogène dans la famille royale
que c'est extrêmement difficile
elle a même sans vraiment le dire dit
qu'elle était plus ou moins victimes de
racisme aussi donc il ya plusieurs
choses qui sont ressorties ces dernières
années qui font en sorte que la
monarchie n'est plus aussi célébré et
mais même par des monarchistes des
royalistes donc le prince charles se
retrouve avec un royaume qui va
peut-être éclaté
une famille royale qui est extrêmement
critique et dans les journaux son frère
qui a accordé des entrevues son fils son
propre fils qu'il a critiqué sur les
chaînes américaines donc il va falloir
qu'il arrive à rassembler tout le monde
et les britanniques ne sont pas très
friand de sa femme camilla elle est
devenue reine consort l'a rennes l'a
annoncé mais même si la reine à 10 voix
laquelle il a toujours été là aux côtés
de mon fils je lui fais confiance elle
va être reine consort et elle est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
les britanniques ne sont pas très
d'accord avec cette idée là parce que
pour eux c'est elle qui est vraiment la
responsable de l'éclatement du mariage
du prince charles avec diana c'est à
cause d'elle que ce couple anne n'a pas
tenu on se souvient en entrevue que
princesse de la princesse diana avait
accordée à bbc en dix ans nous étions
trois dans ce mariage en faisant
référence à cannes il haïssait les
britanniques ne l'ont jamais oublié on
connaît les circonstances de la mort de
la princesse diana et les gens se sont
vraiment tournés vers les deux petits
fils des deux fils de diana le prince
william et le prince harry qui sont un
peu les fils de l'angleterre et c'est
plutôt le prince william qu'ils
aimeraient voir accéder au trône ils
disent ils à 40 ans il a une très jolie
famille une très belle pas m'enfin bref
les britanniques aiment beaucoup le
prince william aussi parce que c'est le
fils de diana et donc dès le départ le
prince charles même s'il va faire tout
ce qu'il peut pour pouvoir avoir
l'affection des britanniques et vous
soutirer il aura certainement un peu
mais il n'aura peut-être pas le même
amour le même dévouement que les
britanniques ont eu envers la reine dont
beaucoup de défis d'attendre longtemps
croit bien merci hazeb et on va
poursuivre maintenant avec arnaud de la
grange et les écrivains et les
journalistes à londres monsieur lagrange
bon soir
ou tôt alors ma collègue parlait de de
la popularité du prince charles il y
avait eu à un moment donné les
discussions peut-être qu'il allait
abdiquer en faveur de son fils et ça ça
s'est terminé est-ce que ça sa
popularité remonter maintenant dans les
dernières années ou pas
oui alors il y avait en effet ces
rumeurs qui disaient qu après tout
charles ayant 73 ans n'étant pas si
populaire que ça mais à la monarchie
enjamberait d'une certaine manière son
son règne pour peu que le
trône passe directement à williams alors
en fait ce qui se passe il faut mettre
un petit bémol à ce que faisait votre
corps washington qui a raison évidemment
sur beaucoup de choses la pobla l'art
elle était tellement populaire
évidemment où la popularité de deschacht
est bien moins absolument rien à voir il
a été longtemps d'ailleurs mal aimé il
s'estimait mal compris traiter un peu
comme un personnage un peu falot quand
même ces dernières années et il est sa
cote de popularité n'a cessé de monter
alors elle n'est n'atteint évidemment
pas les sommets de ceux de sa mère mais
n'a cessé de monter et calmes il ya
maintenant ça a changé quand même
évidemment qu'une certains britanniques
lui reproche toujours ce qui s'est passé
au moment de
de la sphère diana ça c'est certain mais
en même temps en même temps elle aussi
sa popularité n'a cessé de s'améliorer
et parce que les britanniques d'une
certaine manière sont assez touché quand
même par cette histoire d'amour entre
charles et camilla qui dure contre vents
et marées et calmes il ya une certaine
vraiment une intelligence des situations
de ce qu'on serait discrète juste là
quand il faut donc voilà évidemment pour
charles il ya des défis à relever ça
c'est vrai mais en même temps
il il a quand même il y aurait son image
alors après saura-t-il moderniser et
lancer la monarchie dans quelque chose
de nouveau on sait qu'ils veulent à
resserrer parce que comme l'a rappelé
votre correspondante qui a eu cette
histoire andrew lé les histoires harry
et mégane la monarchie a été secoué par
un certain nombre d'histoires familiales
plus ou moins sordides et donc ils
voudraient lui remettre de l'ordre un
peu dans tout ça mais
certains estiment que c'est peut-être
williams c'est à dire le coup d'après
william et kate initieront vraiment un
nouveau visage pour pour la monarchie
britannique qui représente plus l'avenir
en fait de cette monarchie plus moderne
moins jeunes
comment ça va se passer dans les
prochains jours on sait que il sera
officiellement déclaré roy demain c'est
ça
alors il est déjà ce que l'automatique
mans où il est roi et d'ailleurs là la
première ministre sadi voilà a rendu
hommage à sa majesté charles iii il y
avait une incertitude vont se demander
s'il est les garder le nom de charles
pour renier ou s'il allait s'appeler
genre je sais c'est tranché apparemment
c'est charles iii donc il est roi
automatiquement demain quand même il ya
il sera intronisé plus officiellement il
y aura y aura quelque chose au parlement
je crois qu'on l'a perdu
notre collègue à londres oui on l'a
perdu alors on va
qui journaliste à la retraite
spécialiste de la politique et de la
monarchie bonjour monsieur emery
alors on va poursuivre un peu dans cette
cette conversation sur l'état d'esprit
un peu des britanniques dites moi c'est
une grande perte j'imagine pour vous et
pour la plupart des gens
oui comme le nouveau wadi bien n'est ce
pas c'est un moment de grande tristesse
pour toute la population britannique est
sans doute pour beaucoup
tony key words
cette reine a été
respectée et bien aimée pour son devoir
pour cent
la stabilité qu'elle a amené dans la vie
politique britannique qui était
tellement turbulent mais elle était la
constante et on a perdu maintenant
explique c'est un peu ça qui explique
l'attachement très grand très fort des
britanniques pour elle
oui absolument
parce que c'était quelqu'un qui était au
dessus de la politique du sport et elle
était
si je puis dire la personnification de
la stabilité et de la continuité
politique
elle était bien aimé % et elle était
en constant dans l'abri britannique
maintenant tout a changé on sait bien
que le prince charles maintenant le roi
charles iii n'a pas été populaire lors
de la mort de diana il y a vingt cinq
ans et demi sa femme elle était elle est
devenue sa femme camille lien mais le
temps passe et je crois que beaucoup de
britanniques ont maintenant s'ils n'ont
pas pas perdre à pardonner ils ont
oublié un peu ça il est évident que
charles va deux miroirs hilairois
maintenant et que demain comme il ya va
être ça comme on dit en anglais de
crimes qu'on saute c'est la reine même
nom c'est rennes qui l'a nommé comme ça
et il a aperçu reprises un staff une
surprise que la reine
décide statut que camélia allait devenir
reine on s'était un peu sur renault mais
comme j'ai dit dans toutes les familles
de député je te dis mais camilla a été
on va accepter pour marraine et toute la
cour britannique mm pour le grand public
totalement pas totalement il reste
toujours des gens qui ne pardonnerai
jamais ce que s'est passé avec tarn mais
voilà on est là il y avait certains gens
qui veulent qu'ils auraient voulu que le
trône grâce à prince william mais
c'était le ridicule ça ça n'existe pas
dans la constitution britannique qui n'a
pas et qui n'est pas écrite mais quand
même il y a mais le prince de galles qui
succède à la reine et maintenant c'est
william qui est le prince aga khan a
conservé sa mais voilà il est là yg
l'air me l'héritier voilà désigné et je
crois que en tout cas dans ce moment de
grande à ce type d instabilité
britannique politique actuellement avec
la guerre du crâne et avec tous les
problèmes de nrj le grand prix est tout
ça je crois que voilà on va accepter ce
transfert de la souveraineté à
le nouveau roi charles et quel sera son
plus grand défi d'après vous une fois
qu'il devient roi donc vous parler de
tisser ses difficultés politiques en ce
moment et une nouvelle toute nouvelle
première ministre qui est entré en poste
aussi mais qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce
que vous pensez qui sera son plus grand
défi
où il peut personne n'aurait pas prédit
ça n'est ce pas que de 10 jeux tournent
tous deux jours de l'acceptation par la
reine ancien de ce nouveau premier
ministre doit d'abord elle est morte et
un nouveau roi etc
je vois que ça me change rien à la
politique
c'est très difficile de dire exactement
ce qui va se passer en dragon boat match
parce que
le parti conservateur est très divisé le
parti du gouvernement
et personne ne sait si ces trois
ministres va durer elle a hélas en
principe deux ans avec avant l'élection
générale mais qui sait elle est très
impopulaire pour le moment personne ne
sait ce qui va se passer actuellement au
parlement il y à un nouveau plan pour
stabiliser le prix de l'énergie etc mais
c'est très gros traverse énorme on peut
pas exagéré de controverse actuellement
on a un grand match mais voilà à vivre
la mort de la reine et tout ça on va
avoir une sorte de transition
legrand les grandes funérailles a été ta
d'ici dix jours ça va si je puis dire
arrêtez le grand 32 rebelles et on va
voilà si je puis dire on voit même
réaliser la reine et tout ce qui s'est
passé après ça c'est l'orage qui
recommence
et vous disais il va arriver il arrive
nouveau roi charles une période très
difficile pour les britanniques le coût
de la vie l'inflation mais revenons sur
la reine elizabeth vous qu'est ce que
vous retenez d'elle sur le plan
personnel
vous savez j'étais un jeune officiel
dans la l'armée de l'air britannique
lorsque son père est mort et nous on a
été obligé d'aligner la route des
funérailles de georges 6
finalement lorsque j'ai dit
correspondant à washington pour le times
de londres ma femme et moi ont été
présentés à la règle formidable c'était
elle était là pour le
grand célébration de la constitution
américaine
elle était fascinante c'est une femme
qui ne voient pas d'autre l'autre bout
rentrer à rennes elle vous regarde
elle ne elle ne regrette pas ailleurs
elle vous elle est concentrée sur vous
pendant la minute que vous avez avec
elle et puis avancer elle parle avec ma
femme c'est la même chose concentration
totale elle demande à ma femme
comment cette de de vivre à washington
est ce que c'est difficile et ces voix
là incroyable c'était une expérience
humiliante parce qu'elle dégage beaucoup
de gentillesse en fait cette femme quand
on la rencontre évidemment comme
journaliste nous l'avons croisé aussi
très peu de temps évidemment mais quand
elle est venue au canada mais dont
qu'elle dégage cette gentillesse aussi
cette attention qu'elle vous accorde
oui vous savez lorsqu'on aime au maroc
notre homme est reine il faut pas
regarder ailleurs parce que tout le
monde vous regarde ça c'est l'essentiel
et elle a toujours joué sur ça c'était
une trahison qu'elle avait à se
concentrer sur tout ce dont tout lé
monde tout le monde qu'elle rencontrait
ch que ce soit ici ou canada ou afrique
ou en australie elle était voilà le
bien-aller tout le monde tout le monde
qu'il a reconnu qu'ils ont acquis la
rencontre
nous n'oublierons jamais ce qui s'était
passé dans cette minute de d'entretien
on a beaucoup dit qu'elle était sur le
plan de chef d'état par fait que
peut-être sa faiblesse ça a été
peut-être avec sa famille est ce que
vous diriez est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça qu'elle n'a peut-être
pas été aussi une bonne mère peut-être
qu'elle a été une chef d'une grande chef
d'état
qui sait quelle famille le sport elle
elle a trois enfants qui ont été
déboursés
ça n'a pas dû être facile pour elle est
ce qu'elle était une bonne mère qui sait
c'est l'histoire qui jugeraient c'est
évident que les enfants l'aiment bien on
met
succès de parenté de mères et pères etc
au début de leur mariage qui sait n'est
ce pas charles âme est aussi en jeu tous
sont déboursés
c'est parce que c'est pas exactement une
bonne exemple mais on n'en a pas on a
jamais reproché à la mène pour ça c'est
drôle enfin parce que normalement dans
une famille en direct or qu'est-ce que
c'était commerce qui a laissé tous à
développer mais non la reine était ivre
au prochain
irréprochable et on voit là tous ces
gens qui viennent lui rendre hommage et
encore à portée de déposer un bouquet de
fleurs devant buckingham on a senti une
très grande émotion quand la nouvelle
est finalement tombée même si les gens
c'est attendait donc c'est beaucoup de
tristesse aujourd'hui un de votre côté
oui c'est qu'est ce que je peux dire
c'était attendu mais quand même 7 et le
choc parce que on avait tellement
habitude de regarder la reine comme une
sorte de personnes indestructible n'est
ce pas sans mère avait sont deux ans
tout le monde a dit or vous savez le
rennais elle durera jusqu'à 120
le traitement de médecine moderne
qu'elle a utilisés et et elle est sombre
et toujours été dans une santé très
robuste jusqu'à la fin ici vous regardez
le photo d'elle avec le nouveau premier
ministre il ya deux jours elle était un
peu fragile évidemment pas de 96 mais
grandir ou un grand sourire debout
habillé en nacre 16 à manama
au château de balleroy incroyable
personne était voilà prêt pour l'amour
de l'art l on peut dire que ça oui alors
malheureusement c'est ce qui est arrivé
ça s'est accéléré au cours des dernières
heures des deux derniers jours en fait
ça si ça sa santé s'est vraiment
détérioré monsieur emery merci beaucoup
de ces témoignages de ceux de ses
commentaires merci
de long à carla parce que carla vous
avez d'autres réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux il doit y en avoir beaucoup il
ya énormément de messages qui ont
commencé donc apparaître sur les réseaux
sociaux peut-on après le décès de la de
la reine mais avant de passer ses
messages permettez moi de vous montrer
ce qu'on voit sur le site web de la
famille royale on dirait un site web qui
est en deuil
donc cette page qui est noir et qui nous
annonce donc le décès de la reine
elizabeth très rapidement il ya eu un
message qui est venu sur les réseaux
sociaux une dernière photo de la reine
sur justement la page twitter de la
famille royale ensuite à peu près une
quarantaine de minutes après cette photo
il ya une publication d'une déclaration
de maintenant le roi charles iii c'est
comme ça qu'il faut l'appeler qui donne
le ton déjà sur cette période que doit
traverser la famille royale qui dit la
mort de ma mère tenté mais est pour moi
un grand moment de chagrin donc on voit
tout de suite qu'il ya énormément de
tristesse au sein de la famille royale
allons maintenant voir ses réactions
commençons au royaume uni l'archevêque
de canterbury c'est lui qui est à la
tête de donc de l'église anglicane au
royaume uni qui dit nous avons perdu la
personne dont la loyauté inébranlable le
service et l'humidité nous ont aidé à
donner un sens à ce que nous sommes au
cours de décennies de changements
extraordinaires dans notre monde notre
nation et notre société je vous présente
maintenant court message qui est venue
de la première ministre de l'eco ce qui
dit un moment profondément triste pour
loi le royaume uni dont keith inclut
également dans cette vague de tristesse
qui traverse le pays
du côté de l'europe le président de la
commission
du conseil plutôt européen charles
michel qui dit autrefois surnommée
elisabeth l'inébranlable elle n'a jamais
manqué de nous montrer par son service
et son engagement l'importance des
valeurs durables dans un monde moderne
reste en europe pour aller voir du côté
du président de la france emmanuel
macron qui lui a également donc soumis
un message comme ça sur les réseaux
sociaux disant sa majesté la reine
elizabeth ii a incarné la continuité et
l'unité de la nation britannique
plus de soixante dix ans durant je garde
le souvenir d'une amie de la france une
reine de coeur qui a marqué à jamais son
pays et son siècle il ya bien sûr des
réactions qui viennent d'ailleurs donc
ailleurs sur la planète notamment des
états unis avec le président américain
qui dit une femme d'état d'une dignité
et d'une constance incomparable plus
qu'une monarque elle incarnait une
époque dernière réaction que j'ai pour
vous pour vous montrer donc celle du
premier ministre israélien qui lui dit
une dirigeante unique est une figure
exceptionnelle qui symbolisait la
dévotion et l'amour pour sa patrie
j'aimerais maintenant vous montrer une
photo c'est une indication qui nous a
permis de voir avant même qu'on annonce
la mort d'elizabeth 2 kinyinya qu'il n'y
avait pas de changement de garde imprévu
au palais de buckingham donc il y avait
comme seul des signaux qui ont été émis
au long de la journée et pour ceux qui
aiment les chiffres comme moi quelques
dates quelques jalons pour vous montrer
un peu cette longévité de règne de la
reine elizabeth donc 1952 c'est à ce
moment qu'il est nommée reine du royaume
uni elle est couronné l'année suivante
1953 en 2015 elle devient la reine ou la
monarque britannique ayant été le plus
longtemps sur le trompe parce qu'en 2015
elle dépasse la reine victoria qui avait
été la plus de 63 ans 63 ans 7 mois et
deux jours et finalement 2012 on célèbre
donc 70 ans de seringue alors vous
comprenez cette longévité qui a durée
dans le temps et pourquoi les gens sont
si marc hé oui c'est le commentaire qui
me plaisent le plus frappé car là c'est
celui du prince enfin du roi charles le
3 cas parce que c'est vrai que lui
devient roi et en même temps il vient de
perdre sa mère c'est une énorme perte il
parle de son chagrin c'est un deuil qui
doit traverser merci beaucoup car là
maintenant nous rejoignons stephen
clarke il est journaliste écrivain
britannique il vit à paris l'auteur du
livre et elizabeth ii où l'humour
souverain bonjour monsieur clark
l'humour souverain donc vous avez
beaucoup parlé des relations entre
matelas la reine et les différents
premier ministre c'était quand même une
relation très proche
oui parce que normalement la haine vous
voyez les premiers ministres une fois
par semaine pendant le parlement elle
n'a pas elle n'avait pas le droit
d'intervenir dans la politique
quotidienne bien sûr mais en mai presque
tous les premiers ministres dont regard
des banques vraiment comme une source
expérience après tout le premier premier
nice avec qui a trouvé c'était winston
churchill c'était quand même quelqu'un
c'était quelqu'un d'un certain poids en
terme de politique et donc elle avait
deux des conseils parce que chaque fois
que gouvernement contre une crise
c'était pas la première fois que la
haine a valu cette crise donc elle avait
des conseils donc oui il a eu deux très
proches rapport avec plein de premier
ministre elle l a eu des problèmes au
début apparemment avec marg et atx qui
se prenait un peu comme une manne pour
une reine elle même
mais oui elle en fait ce qui est
difficile c'est que les premiers
ministres n'ont pas le droit de révéler
ce qui se passe dans la
pendant le rendez vous et je n'ai jamais
filmée comment on voit votre premier
ministre avec la reine lasser les
rencontres avec nos premiers ministres
pesée qui ne sont pas filmés de sap a
enregistré donc on ne sait pas du tout
ce qu'ils disent mais mais
en même si là elle n'avait pas le droit
d'intervenir dans la politique on peut
bien imaginer que parfois il ya eu un
peu de folie chez les politiciens que
elle a dû commenter d'un point de vue
historique elle qui connaissait depuis
tellement longtemps l'histoire de notre
pays et la pub et la
dignité
elle représentait quand même une figure
d'autorité pour les politiciens avaient
connu winston churchill quand même
oui autorités par les calmes juridique
pas politique mais il ne souhaitait
puisque elle était très très respecté
par les chefs d'état de presque tous les
pays du monde ce qui est impressionnant
chauffe il ya des gens qui sont contre
le privilège qu'ils ont là l'impression
que la haine passer tout son temps
assise dans un palais que c'était un
monde des riches et cette somme est en
fait elle a beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
pour la grande bretagne pour vous comme
noir en essayant de réunir les pays
après la fin de l' empire britannique
elle a quand même été là pour assembler
plein des nations deux hommes de
kambouaré un groupe de pays amis elle
est et il faut dire que je pense qu'elle
a été la chef d'état
la moins raciste de la planète dans les
années 60 quand l assemblée des chefs
d'état africains à autour d'elle
donc et on sait que plusieurs fois la
souris les rapports entre la grande
bretagne et les etats unis pendant des
moments de difficulté par sa présence
par le fait qu'elle elle s'entendait
bien avec tout le monde et parce que ont
respecté cette dame il quand même avait
vécu personnellement toute l'époque de
politique malheureusement le temps file
mais parlez nous de la personnalité de
cette reine puisque il ya quand même un
contraste avec une reine qui prend son
rôle très au sérieux et ça personne
quelle qu'elle ne prenait pas au sérieux
du tout enfin c'est ce qu'on dit
oui exactement c'est pour ça que j'ai
écrit ce livre
parce qu'elle est là elle avait un sens
de l'humour aurait elle même comme une
petite dame très petit âne êtres humains
et ce décalage avec le symbole national
lequel était donc elle elle même comme
femme elle elle ne se prenait pas au
sérieux apparemment une fois plus une
série quand il était petit et là il la
regardait à la télé il a dit avec elle
était là en train de regarder l'émission
il a dit mes grands mères tu ressembles
à miss piggy démocrite
hilarant
mais dépendant avant son couronnement
avec l'archevêque de canterbury pour
détendre l'atmosphère avec tous ces gens
très stressée elle demander à
l'archevêque de lui donner un petit coup
dans le dos pour l'adema pour pour
qu'elle entre dans la capitale donc
c'est toujours ça mais vraiment je dois
vous interromps monsieur claque parce
que c'est tout le temps qu'on a mais
merci beaucoup de vos commentaires c'est
très précieux merci ok
[Musique]
ans
il ya beaucoup plus haut
[Musique]
pourquoi je my way vérifie dans mon show
j'ai envie de véhiculer retrait
[Musique]
comment plus grand désir est que dans
les années à venir
[Musique]
et rester ainsi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va nous aider
c
passé il faut maintenant
et
suite à ce fait
[Musique]
qu'est ce que sean
mais je suis comme de graves crimes en
cause
powell paru
[Musique]
inévitable et
l'ong life
parmi les mensonges
my eyes les chercheurs
des
tidjanes fils john refuse
à socialiser
yvetot m
[Musique]
ici céline galipeau bonjour mesdames
messieurs ça fait donc deux heures et
demi qu'on a appris le décès de la reine
elizabeth 2 elle s'est éteinte
paisiblement à l'âge de 96 ans après un
très long règne c'est le plus long règne
de l'histoire du royaume uni soixante
dix ans 7 mois et deux jours c'est le
palais de buckingham qui a fait
l'annoncé par un tweet qui prouvent que
les temps changent quand même un tweet à
13h30 heure de montréal à londres le
deuil est déjà commencée le drapeau est
en berne sur le palais de buckingham et
les gens se rassemblent devant le palais
de buckingham colloque comme lors du
décès de diana la bbc a joué l'hymne
national annonce de ce décès s'est donc
d'un processus de transition qui
s'enclenche puisque charles est
automatiquement immédiatement devenu roi
il a choisi le titre charles iii donc
dès la mort de sa mère il est devenu roi
je vous présente à nouveau nos invités
de spécialiste de la monarchie estelle
boutillier s'agisse de la monarchie
britannique
marc laurendeau journalistes analystes
lui aussi alors je le disais quand même
c'était une surprise dans la mesure où
la reine est apparu il ya deux jours
assez en forme souriante mais là on a
appris ça c'était des terriers
détériorer très rapidement madame
bouthillier oui c'est comme vous dites
les photos qu'on a vu de son sa
rencontre avec la nouvelle premier
ministre mardi elle était tout sourire
debout évidemment comme elle l'était en
écosse habillé avec des vêtements des
vêtements écossais et
on sentait la qu'elle était en forme
malgré le fait que on pouvait apercevoir
des équipes uniquement sur sa main mais
il reste que elle ne semblait pas du
tout
faible ou fragiles oui mais mais pas au
point de ne pas
faire ses fonctions officielles et on
sait que bon on a vu l'image avec la
nouvelle première ministre mais
auparavant elle avait passé une heure
avec le premier ministre sortant boris
johnson et même après cette rencontre
avec la nouvelle premier ministre et le
prix
quelques quelques temps à lire les
fameuses boîtes rouges qu'elle reçoit
tous les jours même en vacances donc
ce qui s'est passé entre
mardi et où ce matin eh bien on peut on
n'a pas eu de détails sur les raisons
exactes
de ce décès mais peut-être qu'on nous
donnera l'information plus tard mais
reste que ça a été très soudain et comme
elle avait dit lors de son discours à
l'âge de 18 ans qu'elle était pour
servir
son peuple qu'elle meurt jeune ou
vieille bien c'est ce qu'elle a fait et
elle le fait jusqu'à la dernière minute
jusqu'à la fin c'est quand même une vie
incroyable qu'elle aura vécu marque et
on peut imaginer le choc
évidemment on voit ces gens là qui
viennent qui sont rassemblés devant
buckingham palace qui amènent des gerbes
de fleurs et 7 ce grand choc un que
cause sa disparition parce que bien des
britanniques n'ont connu que la reine
elizabeth à de toute leur vie il ya le
choc affectif pour les britanniques
parce qu'ils étaient attachés nous on
est un peu plus à distance mais les
britanniques sont attachés il avait des
nouvelles d'elle tous les deux trois
jours alors c'est un personnage central
2 de leur fonctionnement elle incarnait
l'institution elle est la mémoire de
l'institution il ya cette dimension là
mais il nous vivons aussi une journée
historique là c'est un changement de
règne elle a pu garder les écluses
pendant qu'ils avaient su toutes ces
transformations dans la presse dans les
moeurs elle ait pu garder le prestige de
la monarchie et si ça avait été
quelqu'un d'autre ce n'est pas si sûr
que ce serait bien fonctionné alors ça
c'est tout le talent est en fait la
détermination la fidélité d'elizabeth ii
on parlait tout à l'heure du
commonwealth ça a été sa cause c'est à
dire que l c'était l'idée de ligue et
des pays
ensemble avec des valeurs communes
parlementaires et de de partager un
certain nombre d'intérêts économiques ou
si le commonwealth
ça a été une réussite grâce à elle elle
est là de cette manière là réchappé
l'empiré britannique et il est remis en
question aujourd'hui le commonwealth
regardez c'est le colonialisme on parle
pas de ça il ya dix quinze ans mais
maintenant une mentalité anti coloniale
et quand le prince les jeunes prince
william et même charles sont allés dans
les caraïbes et sauf il ya des gens qui
auront aussi leur façon de penser là
vous allez pas nous coloniser encore
alors il ya quand même un mouvement de
libération dans les caraïbes ce
mouvement libération noirs ou latinos et
la reine traître était très embêté par
sa et ses fils qui récoltait le
mécontentement ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que ça pourra plus jamais
pareil elle est là des réussites à son
actif la reine c'est elle qui en servant
de certains premier ministre brian
mulroney ont fait passer l'idée qu' il
fallait boycotter l'afrique du sud que
le racisme était pas une valeur
acceptable pour commonwealth de ses
réussites et malgré les réticences un de
la première ministre de l'époque malgré
tout à fait j'ai entendu votre éviter
tout à l'heure on était vraiment sur la
même longueur d'onde il y avait à
l'égard autres thatcher et la reine est
pas d'atomes crochus parce que il ya des
choses qui sont sortis c'est mes
meetings là quoi qu'on en dise l'art
elle trouvait que nature passé son temps
à faire la leçon est salée mais poste
vraiment pas deuxième chose palier des
gens de sa famille qui avaient des
intérêts en afrique du sud et pour
diverses raisons idéologiques
elle était favorable au maintien de
l'apartheid et la reine on la
considérait que c'est une valeur
destructrice à l'intérieur comme elle
doit tu es habilement par diplomatie
parce que à cause l'obligation de
réserve pourquoi intervenir directement
c'est une de ses réussites ça d'avoir
réussi à ce qu'on
voie d'être parvenu à ce qu'on boycotte
l'afrique du sud et que ce régime n'a
plus d'autre choix que de capituler et
finalement s'ils voulaient survivre
d'abord donné apartheid alors le
commonwealth a été beaucoup là-dedans
mais ce que je vous disais au départ
puis j'ai écouté le reportage de notre
consoeur sophie langlois qui était axé
là-dessus c'est que
oui c'est une réussite mais là s'est
remis en question la cause de la du
colonialisme il y en a il ya des pays
des caraïbes qui disent nous on veut
peut être là dedans ou alors on veut
plus la monarchie ou à leur station de
république
autrement dit la famille en particulier
chars maintenant vont avoir une
grosse côte à remonter leurs pour que
pour faire accepter le camp mondiale
c'est plus comme avant c'est plus comme
avant de scooter madame outillés un mot
sur charles donc charles iii qui va qui
va qui arrive évidemment une période
très difficile on le sait maintenant
dans le pays avec l'inflation une
nouvelle plume toute nouvelle première
ministre
une certaine instabilité politique donc
il arrive à une période un peu trouble
il a de grands défis devant lui oui mais
je convaincu qu' il va être capable de
les relever et il voit surtout aussi
apporter un changement qui va lui être
propre c'est sûr la reine avait ses
idées sa façon de fonctionner mais la
prince charles a aussi
ses depuis le temps qu'il est comme on
dit
on attend
la tente du trône et il est le prince
héritier qui a été le plus longtemps
donc c'est certain que il sait très bien
aussi que son règne ne sera jamais aussi
là
qu'ils vont vouloir apporter des
changements et c'est sur les changements
ne se font pas dans les prochaines
semaines mais au cours des prochains
mois des prochaines années il va avoir
un certain nombre de choses qui vont
être modifiés et je crois que le
commonwealth
l'idée du commonwealth et
et parmi là les priorités il va vouloir
apporter des changements à cette
institution là qu'est ce qu'on en fait
est ce qu'on l'a boli et sinon comment
on peut l'améliorer l'amener à ce qu'on
vit maintenant au 21ème siècle et tout
ça dans l'harmonie pour essayer le moins
possible de déranger ce qui est déjà
établi c'est certain que il y aura pas
la tâche facile mais en même temps moi
je me dis le fait qu'ils aient un
nouveau premier ministre qui entre en
bourse
les deux sont nouveaux dans leurs tâches
et ensemble je suis certain qu'ils vont
pouvoir
apporter la des changements c'est sur la
première ministre elle a des tâches
extrêmement
précises à faire et plus rapidement que
le prêcheur leroy charme et y reste que
ils vont très bien fonctionner ensemble
pour justement à ce que la transition on
l'a vu déjà depuis certain nombre de
mois une transition qui se fait il sait
lui chaos que lui le discours du
parlement au printemps il rennes avait
délégué peu à peu beaucoup de
plaisir et on a vu que les britanniques
dans tout ça ben ils étaient ils il
s'est est conscient que la reine elle
n'est pas éternelle mais que l'or elle
permettait à challes si je peux dire de
se faire la main aux tâches que
maintenant sont les siennes et
je suis convaincu que les britanniques
vols vont l'appuyer dans ses nouvelles
tâches et comme le disait quelqu'un
auparavant sa cote de popularité ne
cesse d'augmenter et on se rend compte
que maintenant
il et il est prêt il est très près pour
la tâche qui est maintenant est la
sienne et
faut pas oublier non plus que dans tout
ce qu'on vous lisiez evil 2 et vit un
deuil important maintenant lui et sa
famille s'est pas seulement lui mais met
tout le monde autour chaque un père une
mère un grand mère une arrière grand
mère et sont aussi dont le cg quand on
vit un deuil de quelqu'un comme ça qui a
été proche de nous c'est pas facile et
en plus il doit le vivre devant tout le
monde et
faire fonctionner la machine c'est sûr
qu'il ya tout un entourage autour de lui
me reste que je me souviens qu'il avait
fait un commentaire il ya plusieurs
années qu'ils disaient cet affreux
devoir penser que la tâche que je vais
un jour accomplir il faut que ma mère
meurt pour que je l'oeil c'est c'est
mais ces appareils et la reine aux
véhicules à même la même chose en 1952
et je suis convaincu que ils en ont
discuté ensemble pour
autant la reine peut-être voulu lui dire
ben écoute c'est comme ça que les choses
doivent se faire et la vie doit
continuer il va avoir des changements
mais
il ya tellement là dans l'immédiat
l'accession officielle
le discours d'accession ensuite ça va
être les les je suis convaincu qu'il va
avoir une chapelle ardente les
funérailles d'un an près d'une dizaine
de jours et après ça là ça va être
vraiment l'air de la reine elizabeth
deux bords se clore et c'est vraiment
après les funérailles que la même si les
règles va avoir commencé le dizaine de
journées plutôt le règne de charles va
vraiment débuter après ses funérailles
et là doucement mais sûrement énormément
de changements vont être apportées à
tous les niveaux et ça va deux touchés
ici aussi parce que comme on le disait
dans beaucoup dans toutes nos
institutions tout est fait en parlant de
l'arrêt de maintenance et le roi donc ce
n'est plus
dieu sauve la reine cdu sauve le roi
comme hymne national donc il ya
énormément
de
d'aspects à tous ce changement que l'on
va vivre dans les prochaines semaines
des prochains mois et le président russe
vladimir poutine a lui aussi réagi donc
il a salué la mémoire de la reine
elizabeth il a présenté ses condoléances
à son fils ou vos roi charles iii
pendant de nombreuse dessine décennies
dit le communiqué elizabeth 2 jouissait
à juste titre de l'amour et du respect
de ces sujets ainsi que d'une autorité
sur la scène mondiale a indiqué monsieur
poutine dans un communiqué publié par le
kremlin alors tout de suite allons à
washington mme hazeb vous vous envolerez
pour londres ce soir évidemment l'ondé
de choc on la sent un peu partout dans
le monde absolument vous venez de
souligner les condoléances de vladimir
poutine s'est vraiment à l'unanimité
même ici à la maison blanche le drapeau
est en berne dans plusieurs pays
également vous savez la reine quitte
quand même une somme monde avec les une
guerre en europe il ya son royaume uni
qui va peut-être éclaté après le après
le break 6 donc elle quitte quand même
seconde dans une situation assez
précaire mais il faut le dire beaucoup
de gens beaucoup de chefs d'état ont
souligné l'importance qu'elle avait et
faut parler aussi des funérailles et la
madame bouttier venait de le souligner
ça va être énorme ça va être très drôle
imaginé plusieurs dirigeants du monde
entier vont se rendre à londres il va y
avoir un très important contingent de
sécurité faut assurer la sécurité de
tout le monde en plus des britanniques
qui vont vouloir rendre hommage à la
reine donc ça risque d'être énorme et
puis en même temps en même temps que ses
funérailles là il faut penser au
couronnement là on vient d'apprendre que
le couronnement risque de se produire
d'ici six mois et c'est là qu'on va voir
le prince charles toute la cérémonie
grandiose du prince charles du roi
charles qui sera officiellement si vous
voulez roi charles iii de droit donc
c'est plus rapide que pour pour l'arrêt
elisabeth à elle avait pris un an après
la mort nabeul le décès de son père
absolument donc son père est décédé en
février 1952 elle a été couronnée reine
en juin
1953 et ça a pris quand même à peu près
un an avant qu'elle soit couronnée là on
parle quand même d'ici six mois il sera
couronné roi à 72 ans évidemment on
n'est pas habitué à un couronnement il y
en a pas eu en grande bretagne en a pu
pendant 70 ans donc malgré le fait que
tout a été arrangé méticuleusement que
la mort de la reine était évidemment
inéluctable que ça allait se produire
d'ici les dix prochaines années puisque
rappelons le sa mère la reine mère est
décédée à 102 ans était aussi très bien
préparer ses funérailles donc les
britanniques et tout le contingent de
préparation pour les funérailles de la
reine est déjà prêt ça a été
méticuleusement préparé donc ce n'est
pas une surprise comme ça a été le cas
pour la princesse diana où elle est
décédée personne ne s'y attendait donc
il a fallu s'organiser très rapidement
pour la reine s'est méticuleusement
préparé donc normalement c'est tout et
autour des colis citer que codifier tout
est préparé à la minute près en fait
depuis les années oui absolument et vous
savez la bbc vous le soulignez tout à
l'heure c'est le code c'était london
bridge s going down et ben chaque année
ils pratiquaient justement si la reine
meure comment s'organisent les émissions
tv qui fait quoi où donc ça fait des
années que non seulement la bbc se
prépare mais évidemment tout tout le
royaume uni toute la garde rapprochée de
la reine et pied faut souligner le
prince charles qui toute sa vie son rôle
a été d'attendre de devenir roi c'était
un peu ça c'était le prince héritier est
donc là à 72 ans il devient il devient
roi
les gens retiennent un peu leur souffle
et gens le connaissent donc il n'y aura
pas grand surprise mais au départ
certainement qu'il aura le soutien des
britanniques parce qu'il vient de perdre
sa mère et puis aussi parce que c'est la
constitution qui le veut c'est la
tradition c'est lui qui devient roi même
si beaucoup d'entre eux aimeraient voir
très bientôt le prince william accéder
au accéder au trône britannique
mais pour le moment c'est vraiment la
reine qu'on célèbre que les britanniques
célèbres savez il pleut à londres
j'écoutais des entrevues les gens sont
encore sous le choc encore encore
bouleversée de d'imaginer qu'il y aura
que le pays sera sera sans rennes donc
ça reste quand même un choc pour les
britanniques et pendant deux semaines
pendant dix jours ils vont la célébrer
l'on célébrait de son vivant pendant le
jubilé en juin dernier oui là eh ben ça
va être ses funérailles ou vraiment à
l'unanimité marque vraiment un un
parcours sans faute là où elle a
vraiment respecté son oreiller observé
céline cette photo là avec la première
ministre li strauss où elle est à
balmoral où la reine se tient encore
debout c'est quand même assez incroyable
à 96 ans où elle a depuis quand même à
lui serrer la main et si vous regardez
cette photo quand vous regardez la main
de la reine elle un peu bleus y aller un
peu et la reine c'est assez incroyable
et tout au long sans rails même si elle
n'a pas accordé d'entrevue et toujours
eu des petits messages est-ce que là on
les en ne mettant pas de caen par
exemple elle aurait pu mettre des gants
est ce qu'elle voulait dire aussi aux
engrais voilà je suis je suis malade que
je quitte ce monde on se souvient que
pour le brésil elle avait porté une robe
vous savez aux couleurs de l'europe est
bleu et jaune donc à chaque fois il ya
un petit message et leurs devoirs cette
reine quand même qui est très amaigrie
qu'est très amincie qui serre la main de
les choses on voit très bien visiblement
sa main bon elle a peut-être reçu des
injections une main quand même assez
bleui c'était peut-être aussi une façon
pour elle de dire au revoir à son peuple
oui c'était une photo qui a qui a fait
beaucoup réagir justement à cause de de
sa main et de ce que ça voulait dire ou
pas et il y avait eu beaucoup de
questions après ça justement merci hazeb
on va écouter la première ministre
britannique les risques étaient donc
avec la reine à ce moment là et on va
écouter ce qu'elle avait à dire un petit
peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
rendre de balmoral
le décès de sa majesté la reine est un
choc énorme pour la nation et pour le
monde entier
la reine elizabeth ii était le rock sort
lequel la grande bretagne moderne a été
bâti nous avons prospérer sous son règne
la grande bretagne est le grand pays
qu'il est aujourd'hui grâce à elle
aujourd'hui la couronne passe de mai
comme ça a été le cas depuis plus de
mille ans un autre nouveau monarque
notre nouveau chef d'état sa majesté le
roi charles iii
avec la famille du roi nous pleurons la
perte de sa mère et d'un autre de il
nous faut nous rassembler comme peuple
pour le soutenir et avec la passation de
ces deux mrs ou alizée bêtes nous
entrons dans une nouvelle ère dans cette
grande histoire magnifique d'un pays
tout comme sa majesté leur ai souhaité
en prononçant la formule que dieu
protège le roi
la reine du a marqué les esprits par sa
force par son calme ou si elle était
pourtant aux premières loges des grands
événements du 20e siècle donc c'est un
grand personnage historique qui nous
quitte et je demandais que le drapeau du
québec soit en berne sur tous les
édifices publics du gouvernement pour
souligner le décès de la reine elizabeth
ii
6 s
beaucoup de réactions évidemment la
reine était une figure mondiale le pape
françois s'est dit profondément attristé
dans la mort d'elizabeth ii il a rendu
hommage à sa vie de services
indéfectible et son exemple de
dévouement ou de voir il a aussi adressé
ses sincères condoléances à toute la
famille royale donc parlons maintenant
du protocole de ce qui s'en vient dans
les prochains jours de façon peut-être
plus précise avec vous et yasmine
de deuil c'est 1 2 qui a été longtemps
planifié l'opération porte le nom
opération london bridge alors à partir
du à partir du décès de la reine c'est
le dis dès le jour j par la suite sont
sous son s'en suivront donc les
premières procédures ce qu'il faut faire
ce que savoir c'est que le secrétariat
le secrétariat particulier de la reine
devait ou a informé la première ministre
avec le nom de code de london bridge est
down par la suite est bien le même
secrétariat 20 former les 15
gouvernements des pays dont la reine où
la défunte reine était la chef d'état
est également tous les pays du
commonwealth les 38 pays du commonwealth
par la suite également il va y avoir
l'information qui va circuler dans les
fils de presse mais également on va
annoncer où on va afficher devant la
porte de buckingham palace cette photo
c'est un homme habillé en noir qui va
venir posté cette photo où cette annonce
avec le message suivant que l'on
retrouve également sur l'ensemble des
prêts à appeler cela des plateformes et
des réseaux sociaux sur le site de la
famille royale à rennes est décédé à
balmoral cet après-midi roi et la reine
consort resteront à balmoral ce soir et
reviendront à londres demain jeudi 8
septembre
2022 les drapeaux ont été mis en berne
est ce que ce protocole nous apprend
c'est que l'ensemble donc des
législatures doivent et des bâtiments
publics doivent l'affiché d'un mettre
les drapeaux en berne dans un délai de
dix minutes pas une minute de plus il y
avait également dans certaines
informations comme quoi le thème des
inscrits s'étaient plaints qui ne
pourrait pas effectuer cette tâche
rapidement et rentrer dans ce délai de
temps ceci étant dit le parlement et les
législatures annexes donc de la
nouvelle-écosse du pays de galles est
également de l'irlande du nord seront
également fermés et cesseront toute
activité demain à 11 heures
charles deviendra roi officiellement il
sera intronisé son épouse camilla va
devenir la reine parce que la défunte
reine elizabeth l'avait voulu elle avait
également mentionné par la suite est
bien le roi charles va se rendre en
écosse au pays de galles et en irlande
du nord pour des cérémonies
commémoratives et en l'hommage de la
défunte reine jusqu'au déroulement donc
des funérailles et pendant ce temps-là
westminster hall sera complètement
fermée par la suite et bien il va ya
voir le jour 4 une chapelle ardente à
l'abbaye de westminster on prévoit cinq
cent mille personnes qui pourrait venir
donc se recueillir sur le corps de la
défunte reine qui seraient exposés
pendant 23 heures sur 24 heures et enfin
le dernier jour le dixième jour et bien
ce sera les funérailles officielles de
la reine d'angleterre la reine elizabeth
qui vont se tenir à westminster et par
la suite eh bien elle sera inhumée aux
côtés de son défunt mari le prince
philip et de son défunt père le roi
george c 'est toujours à windsor dans la
chapelle saint georges voilà très clair
merci beaucoup yasmine c'est important
de voir un peu ce calendrier pour voir
comment ça va se dérouler dans les
prochains jours merci beaucoup et
maintenant je et ottawa donc retrouver
louis blouin parce que des blancs voient
évidemment le drapeau canadien qui est
en berne donc sur la tour de la paix et
louis à des gerbes de fleurs qui ont
déjà été déposés on voit les canadiens
veulent rendre hommage à la reine
ouais absolument je me trouve ici
haridwar la résidence de la gouverneure
générale représentante du roi maintenant
au canada il voyait qu ici devant la
résidence il ya le drapeau canadien qui
a été mis en berne tout comme ça a été
le cas effectivement sur la tour de la
paix au centre-ville d'ottawa sur la
cité parlementaire et je vais vous
montrer ici derrière moi parce qu'il ya
des gens qui va s'est régulièrement pour
venir poser des fleurs ici devant la
résidence voyez donc été déposée juste
mais aussi devant la statue de la deux
qui se situe devant l'entrée principale
de rideau à un petit peu plus bas et
c'est intéressant d'entendre les gens
veulent entendre les témoignages qu'elle
a recueillis ma collègue claudine
richard un peu plus tôt on sent vraiment
se lier personnel que les gens ont avec
la reine avait avec la reine elizabeth 2
que ça les touche très personnellement
on peut entendre si vous voulez quelques
témoignages de gens qui ont choisi de
venir se déplacer comme ça ici
[Musique]
pour beaucoup de personnes je pense
beaucoup de personnes avec une grand
mère je pense surtout à notre génération
génération x tout ça donc mais ça c'est
une femme forte c'était voilà je pense
tout n'est pas tout ce qui a été fait
n'était pas parfait puis on lui
demandait pas ça mais je pense était une
femme fait du très bon travail comme
comme rennes c'est certain
oui beaucoup d'hommages justin trudeau
comme d'autres premiers sons à vue
françois legault tout à l'heure le
premier ministre dr légalement il a
réagi et de façon assez émotif quand
même
oui il était ému le premier ministre il
a même versé une larme pendant qu'il
faisait cette allocution un petit peu
plus tôt il dit qu'il pouvait pas croire
que la dernière rencontre le dernier
tête à tête qu'il a eu avec la reine
mais que c'était effectivement le
dernier l'a décrit comme une monarque
qui était sage curieuse intelligente
mais aussi drôle et dit qu'il va
s'ennuyer des conversations qu'il a eues
avec l faut dire qu'il la connaît depuis
très très longtemps il avait rencontré
déjà quand il était enfant alors que
c'est son père qui rencontrait la reine
à ce moment là quand il était premier
ministre justin trudeau a dit qu elle a
accompagné le canada dans son histoire
parce que c'est vrai qu'elle a fait
vingt deux visites au canada au total
elle a côtoyé 12 premiers ministres sur
23 dans l'histoire canadienne si vous
dire comment ces larges la
période qu'elle a couvert dans
l'histoire canadienne et le célèbre des
moments importants comme le rapatriement
de la constitution à 81,2 la cérémonie
de signature rappelez vous si vous
voulez on peut entendre une partie du
mode justin trudeau
là on n'écoute plus tôt l'ancien premier
jean chrétien
bacci oiseaux écoutez elle était une
personne très dévoué
respectable elle était respecté de par
le monde il doit y avoir dix millions de
personnes dans le monde qui sont
formatrices t elle à une très belle vie
elle a toujours fait preuve d'une grande
dignité et elle était une personne très
agréable dans la vie privée j'ai eu le
privilège l'a rencontré en
1967 au moment du centenaire du canada
et je devais l'accompagner lors d'une
cérémonie officielle elle a toujours été
vraiment gracieuse elle parlait toujours
avec mon épouse en français car c'est
une bonne occasion pour elle de
pratiquer son français qui était quand
même assez bon
et c'était la même chose pour la reine
mère non vous savez pour moi
et m'a conféré l'honneur d'être membre
de l'ordre du mérite il n'y avait que
quatre quais les étudiants ont eu cet
honneur depuis 1904 donc pour moi c'est
une grande perte tout comme ça doit être
le cas pour des millions de personnes
par contre
elle méritait le respect qu'on lui
montrais et
elles méritent leur peau qu'on lui à
faire maintenant car je pense que depuis
un mois sa vie est un peu plus difficile
donc de la bns
oiseau de feu j'étais à ses funérailles
très bon ami qui décédé qui avait 93 ans
et c'était à ottawa
quelqu'un qui travaillait sur la colline
parlementaire pour le secteur privé
julij opel
c'était vraiment un grand sportif on le
jouait au golf ensemble le jour ping
pong au billard et il me battait
toujours car il était vraiment très bon
et c'était vraiment très bien d'être là
avec sa famille ses amis donc c'est là
où j'ai appris que la reine était décédé
question inaudible réponse écoutez je
m'y attendais comme plein d'autres vous
avez
elle a été libéré d'une certaine façon
car elle a perdu son mari il ya deux ans
vous savez elle a eu des moments
difficiles c'était son tour finalement
de le rejoindre elle a une très belle
vie écoutez
je suis triste comme j'ai dit comme bien
d'autres autour du monde
je remercie
vous aviez un rapport ainsi facile avec
elle n'est ce pas
connaît-il réponse écoutez je ne sais
trop quoi dire les rencontrer en 67 et
ç'a toujours été amicale entre nous
j'ai rencontré tant de fois vous savez
j'ai eu l'occasion
de
répondre à ces demandes de temps à autre
elle a été très généreuse à mon égard
elle ment à faire le l'ordre du mérite
et je n'étais que le quatrième canadien
depuis 1902 à recevoir cet ordre du
mérite c'était son choix elle
j'étais un homme très chanceux et mon
épouse ou si on a passé quatre ou cinq
jours en
1970 cela nord elle est venue pour le
centenaire des territoires du nord-ouest
et nous avons passé des jours avec et à
bord de l'avion
mon épouse était avec le nouveau roi et
la princesse anne et moi j'étais dans
l'autre avion avec la reine et le prince
philip
pendant des journées entières nous
voyagions ensemble et nous avons eu bien
du plaisir
les
insectes
ministre jean chrétien qui a bien connu
la reine il a raconté qu'il l'avait
rencontré une première fois en 1967 pour
le centenaire du canada il a souligné à
quel point c'est agréable à quel point
c'est une femme aimable et qu'elle
parlait bien français puisque ils
s'étaient parlé en français qu'elle
qu'elle aimait bien d'ailleurs lui
parler en français parce qu'elle ça lui
permettait de pratiquer cette langue
qu'elle ne pratiquait pas si souvent que
ça donc avec sa femme il a rencontré
plus tard ils ont voyagé je joins louis
blouin qui est toujours à tahoua donc
monsieur chrétien qu'on voit moins
souvent ces temps-ci mais qui se
rappelait c'est de bons souvenirs avec
avec la reine
oui il avait une relation qui était très
très spécial entre les deux il l'a
mentionné il a reçu l'ordre du mérite
c'est très très rare elle l'a consulté
comme plusieurs qui ont reçu cet ordre à
plusieurs reprises même après qu'il
était premier ministre monsieur chrétien
et je me permets une petite anecdote
cocasse si vous voulez céline parce que
quand monsieur chrétien était assise à
la cérémonie de rapatriement de la
constitution 82 à côté de la reine pour
signer le document il ya une histoire
qui a beaucoup été racontée où il a
brisé la pointe du crayon avec laquelle
il signait et il a laissé tomber le mot
merde et ça apparemment fait beaucoup
rire la reine à côté d'elle qui s'est
esclaffé et tout ça dansait juste vous
dire cette relation amusante ce jeu bons
liens qu'ils avaient les deux la matière
compte a quitté très très réguliers avec
lui cela dit il ya eu plusieurs
réactions je vous parle un petit peu
plus tôt de monsieur trudeau qui
exactement petit retour en arrière mais
on peut attendre maintenant si vous
voulez monsieur tron
dans un monde très compliqué
sa présence sa graff
sa force
a été une ressource importante
pour nous tous
c'était une de mes personnes préféré au
monde
et elle me manquera énormément
d'autres réactions aussi céline celle de
la gouverneure générale qui a envoyé un
message sur twitter qui dit partout au
pays les canadiens porteront le deuil de
la reine prenons un instant pour honorer
la mémoire de sa majesté chacun à sa
manière fin d'incitations quelques
réactions sur les autres chefs de parti
je commence sur twitter par le chef du
bloc québécois parce qu'on s'est demandé
à coups de quoi aura l'air les réactions
il dit entre autres elle aura été au
coeur d'un siècle troubles avec le désir
d'y être une force positive alors c'est
le mode et françois blanchet le chef du
bloc québécois écoutons si vous voulez
le chef du npd vous allez avoir aussi un
député conservateur
je veux partager ma tristesse mais je
vais aussi partagé mais mes condoléances
aux familles de la reine les espaces
parce qu'elle était mère grand-mère
arrière grand mère et la perte d'une
membre de la famille comme ça c'est une
perte énorme
c'est une dame qui a traversé toutes
sortes d'épreuves toutes sortes de
crises que vu la société changé au fil
des années qui a toujours été la guitare
avec beaucoup de grâce et beaucoup de
prestance donc c'est une grande dame qui
a marqué la vie de nombreux canadiens
mais aussi de nombreux britanniques et
de nombreux citoyens partout dans le
monde qui nous a quittés aujourd'hui
je me permets un petit mot sur la course
conservatrice céline qui doit culminer
je vous le rappelle samedi soir ici à
ottawa le parti a fait savoir que c'est
pas clair pour l'instant si le
rassemblement l'événement qui était
prévue aura lieu ou non on devrait avoir
une mise à jour demain parce qu'on veut
essayer de respecter la les
commémorations qui pourrait avoir lieu
le cas échéant à suivre et il ya le
président de la chambre des communes ici
à ottawa qui a précisé que les députés
de la chambre n'auront pas à prêter
allégeance pour le roi charles iii que
ça se faire un peu se transfère
automatiquement
on verra s'il ya une motion qui sera
adapté adopté à la chambre des communes
éventuellement pour exprimer les
condoléances par rapport au parlement
mais aussi la loyauté envers le nommer
le nouveau monarque ça ça pourrait
survenir également peut-être au cours
des prochaines semaines on verra mais le
président de la chambre a bien rappelé
que le parlement n'est pas dissout on
n'interrompt pas la session
parlementaire ou quoi que ce soit les
choses se poursuivre normalement c'est
toujours la gouverneure générale ici qui
s'occupe de représenter maintenant le
charles le prêt sera en fête le roi
charles iii mais
le chef de l'état canadien oui pas
facile hors la loi on va l'avoir merci
beaucoup oui
alors on parlait de la reine elizabeth 2
kia qui a côtoyé 12 premier ministre au
canadien elle a aussi fait de nombreuses
visites officielles au canada 22 visite
en fait c'est le pays qu'elle a le plus
visité dans le monde les apparitions
toujours rigoureusement planifiée qui
ont suscité l'enthousiasmé des uns mais
aussi les critiques des autres voici ce
qu'a préparé pour nous mathieu papillon
sur les moments marquants
[Applaudissements]
jamais vu c'est en 1957 quatre ans après
son couronnement que la reine elizabeth
2 fait sa première visite officielle au
canada
destination ottawa capitale fédérale
eole ville voisine au québec
21 autres visites officielles ont suivi
entre 1959 et 2010
celle de 1959 aura été la plus longue
quarante cinq jours passés au pays pour
notamment inaugurer la voie maritime du
saint laurent
en 1964 le passage de la reine à québec
et marqués par la répression des
manifestations d'étudiants et
d'indépendantistes c'est ce qu'on
appellera le samedi de la matraque
il ya aussi eu la tournée de 1967 où la
visite de l'ex pour s'imposer
celle de 1976 où la reine s'est encore
rendu à montréal pour les jeux
olympiques cette fois
dans la catégorie des visites plus
politique il y a eu celle de 1992 pour
le rapatriement de la constitution ou
celle de 1992 pour le 125e anniversaire
de la confédération c'est toutes les
photos de sa visite royale au canada en
2002 mais pour andré robichaud il ya
d'abord et surtout eu la visite de 2002
dans sa province le nouveau brunswick
venant d'une région
l'arrivée de moncton c'était déjà au
fait que c'est de faire comme on va être
sur la rue mines pu voir la reine
textait comme des cinq hommes comme si
que j'assistais
comme un spectacle c'était comme si ce
que je tends montréal presque à force
impressionnant pour moi à 16 ans un
enthousiasme visiblement partagée par
certains policiers à l'époque le père
d'andré a pu le constater après avoir
été intercepté pour excès de vitesse
comme n'importe quel produit si l'on
demandé quelle était la raison qui on a
dit mme st aubin on allait voir la
visite de la reine sur la rue main puis
finalement cette excuse l'a affirmé mon
père de se faire
exempter d'une amende journée là qui
n'était pas parfait bonne visite puis
faites lui bonjour c'était quelque chose
de très excitant anne poirier bas ce qui
était à l'époque l'adjointe exécutive de
la ministre claudette bradshaw
aujourd'hui décédé elle était au coeur
de l'organisation de la visite de 2002
un travail qui a duré près d'un an
l'équipe de la reine ne voulant rien
laisser au hasard elle c'est en rentrant
dans un édifice y vas voir quelqu'un là
qui vont lui offrir des fleurs elle sait
que c'est la troisième personne où là
c'est les trois petites filles qui sont
à gauche qui vont lui offrir des fleurs
alors si elle fait quelque chose d'un
pointu elle même et les gardes de
sécurité n'aime pas ça non
mais ce genre de visites et les dépenses
qu'elles impliquent attirent toujours
leur lot de critiques celle de 2002 n'ya
pas échappé les folles ont aussi été
parfois moins imposante qu'espéré tom
aucune idée comme le niveau de sécurité
aussi n'empêche pour plusieurs elizabeth
ii lors a toujours imposé respect et
admiration
moi je vais être en avant d'elle pour la
diriger vers son siège puis calais venu
vers moi j'ai comme figé moi j'avais su
que j'avais comme oublier j'étais
tellement
impressionné de l'avoir c'est ça aussi
qui comme impressionnant puisqu'il
impressionnant encore aujourd'hui de se
sentir que toute sa vie elle s'est
donnée pour son peuple mais denis pour
son travail qui peut pas être avant je
pense que facile d'un côté tu vois
qu'elle portait un chapeau noir avec une
blouse blanche puis je pense qu'elle a
la qualité de la caméra du faune faisait
que je voyais pas que j'ai juste vu
comme la limousine et c'est justement
cette admiration qui l'a poussé à se
rendre à halifax en 2010 voici ma
moquette liste de la vie je pourrais
faire comme je les ai vus deux fois à
quelques mains tg pas été dans les
cérémonies ou dandy dans un truc où j'ai
pu lui serrer la main ou du parent liste
est quand même visuellement mais ça moi
ça fait la job de mon côté d'eux des
dans le même dans le même merkel
d'autant plus que sans le savoir il
assistait ce qui allait devenir la
dernière visite de la reine au pays si
mathieu papillon radio-canada monde
ouais beaucoup d'admiration pour cette
reine qui a été une institution un
pilier qui incarne vraiment si la
demande archives britanniques alors on
va faire maintenant le tour des
réactions au pays en commençant par
montréal mélissa vous êtes sur l'avenue
greene à westmount comment est-ce qu'on
réel et
ça va de soi céline de dire que c'est un
moment qu'on n'a jamais vécu alors cet
après midi on est allé aux réactions on
est allé à la rencontre des montréalais
on a senti une certaine tristesse une
certaine surprise aussi parce qu'il ya
des gens à qui on a annoncé la nouvelle
ce qu'on a senti également sur le
terrain céline c'est quand même une
certaine distance par rapport à la
monarchie britannique à la famille
royale également il ya des gens qui nous
ont dit écoutez c'est une relique d'un
autre temps alors ça je me dois de vous
partager cette réaction là qu'on a eu
mais quand même on a rencontré aussi des
montréalais qui nous ont dit qu'ils
reconnaissent finalement l'importance de
cette perte la aujourd'hui ne serait ce
que nie pas l'importance historique
l'importance de l'institution aussi
qu'elle représente alors je vous prie
d'écouter les réactions qu'on a qu'on a
recueilli un peu plus tôt on est
d'ailleurs tombé sur une dame du royaume
uni de passage à montréal qui aurait
bien voulu être chez elle dans son pays
pour vivre ce moment où on écoute
elle agit
j
avais seulement de respecter l avait
jamais fait des choses qui ont été
mal traitement des personnes toujours
avec l'espère pour tout le reste un bon
modèle pour tous pour moi
personnellement je pense que c'est
ancien symbole qui a vraiment pas de
relève ans aujourd'hui dans notre vie
contemporaine sauf que c'est du mauvais
souvenir vraiment
*
allons tout de suite à la réaction
également céline de valérie plantes
mairesse de montréal qui nous dit nos
pensées accompagnent les proches de sa
majesté elizabeth elle a dédié sa vie au
service public et elle rappelle aussi
qu'il s'agit du plus long règne de
l'histoire du royaume uni et je vais
vous laisser avec ces images céline
parce qu'on est actuellement devant une
galerie d'art je pense que vous la voyez
qui a changé sa devanture avec des
images une oeuvre en fait deux oeuvres
illustrant la reine la reine elizabeth
alors on me disait tout à l'heure à
cette galerie d'art qu'il s'agit d'un
des visages les plus connus dans le
monde et qui a fasciné un bon nombre
d'artistes alors voilà on a changé la la
façade avec une vision un peu plus pop
si vous permettez de la reine
d'angleterre oui intéressant mais c'est
vrai elle a régné pendant 70 ans donc
elle a marqué quand même l'histoire
merci mélissa
allons maintenant du côté de sherbrooke
avec marion bérubé donc on se désole du
départ de l'arenh
voilà même ici à sherbrooke que le décès
de la reine à des écossais line un peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui j'ai pu rencontrer
des aînés qui étaient rassemblés dans un
parc tous s'entendent pour dire que
c'est une énorme perte autant ici à
sherbrooke que la reine d'angleterre a
fait beaucoup pour son pays il ya même
des aînés à qui j'ai parlé qui se
rappellent clairement de ses jeunes
années une dame qui est âgée d'une
douzaine d'années lors du couronnement
de la reine une autre que nous a même
parlé de ses années à titre de jeune
princesse vous avez tout à écouter
quelques réactions
[Musique]
go
je les admire et
parce que la fête se groupent possible
et c'est quelqu'un de valeur que change
en anglais à gauche wever
a à gogo
mais
il ya également la ville de bromont
toujours en esthétique un lien
particulier avec la reine céline parce
que la reine qui étaient présents dans
la ville en 1976 lors des jeux
olympiques pour assister aux épreuves
équestres de la princesse inde donc
aujourd'hui la ville de bromont qui va
mettre son drapeau ses drapeaux en berne
tout comme la ville de sherbrooke oui on
connaît l'amour des chevaux légendaire
de la reine elizabeth merci beaucoup
merci et à québec marie pierre mercier
comment est-ce qu'on réagit la halle
annonce de la mort de la reine
lorsqu'on a appris la nouvelle céline on
s'est rendus l'équipe rbx côté de la
citadelle de québec qui est
immédiatement on a vu les drapeaux du
canada se mettre en berne sachez qu'au
cours des prochains jours les gens qui
vont vouloir aller se recueillir à les
porter des fleurs allés signer un livre
de condoléances à propos cible de le
faire à la citadelle les détails
viendront il y avait très peu de gens
pour réagir à la citadelle aujourd'hui
alors on s'est dirigés ici dans le vieux
québec on a appris la nouvelle à bien
des gens ici pour dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont encore en mode vacances
dans le vieux québec et beaucoup de
touristes m'ont entendu des gens qui
étaient peinés déjà aussi que se
souciait peu de la mort de la reine on
écoute quelques réactions
bon c'est demain mais on a tous une
feuille même qu'au soir à jouer à wau
conçoit n'est pas pkoi attaqué départ
hâtif pas si ça ça m'a jamais touchée la
famille royale mais je trouve que elle
commet comme personne à la fête vraiment
ça me fait de la peine quand je le
voyais régulièrement c'était une bonne
rien on n'a pas été déçu j'ai mal
traitées autrement fout comme de l'an
quarante sept autres des choses qui
devraient pas exister à mon avis et de
la nausée pas qu'aujourd'hui
que c'était une grande dame l'a fait
beaucoup de choses et
c'est bien je pense que
le monde entier va lui rendre hommage ce
qui serait juste
[Musique]
vous savez dans le vieux québec qui lie
à la cathédrale anglicane trinity
roncier un rendu on a vu plusieurs
personnes à liszt recueillir autour des
photos de la reine qui ont été installés
dans cette cathédrale d'ailleurs il ya
un banc qui est réservée pour elle si
jamais elle se présentait à québec sont
maintenant réservées pour le roi
lévesque qui est l'évêque de l'église en
cliquant ici à québec nous disait qu'il
s'attend à recevoir beaucoup de fidèles
au cours des prochains jours parce que
selon lui la reine a marqué énormément
les générations de la communauté
anglicane ici à québec et à partir de
dimanche il ya une chose qui va changer
dans cette cathédrale là les fidèles ne
vont plus prier pour la reine ils vont
prier pour le roy on égoutte les vagues
même une suprise
de se lever ce matin de voir les
nouvelles de ce malade hippie juste
quelques heures après qu'elle est mort
alors c'est sûr que c'est une journée de
tristesse de deuil et très solennelle
aussi
la dernière visite de la reine elizabeth
ii dans la ville de québec remonte à
1987 mais on l'a vu les réactions sont
quand même assez partagés à québec merci
beaucoup marie pierre
prend la direction de toronto maintenant
andréanne williams le premier nice
d'oxford on a entendu de chaleur a
exprimé ses condoléances la famille
royale oui tout à fait il a exprimé ses
condoléances mais il a aussi tenu à
féliciter le nouveau roi d'angleterre
leur charles iii pour son extension au
trône il a voulu vraiment mettre en
lumière ou en fait souligné l'apport de
la reine elizabeth ii dans le monde
durant son règne historique qu'il a
qualifiée d' historique en 70 ans de
règne est aussi son apport au canada
parce qu'elle l'a visité le pays à 22
reprises mais elle a aussi visité un
l'ontario à 18 reprises c'est la
promesse qu'elle a visité le plus
souvent elle est venue à toronto à sept
reprises dont constant via le lien que
pu être créés au fil des décennies entre
la reine elizabeth ii et l'ontario je
vous invite à écouter le premier
ministre doit être
un succès
et on sent bien aussi que les réactions
sont vives à toronto j'ai parlé à
plusieurs torontois qui était très ému
aujourd'hui quand je leur ai posé la
question à savoir comment ils se sentent
et par rapport à la mort d'elizabeth
deux beaucoup d'émotion tout le monde
des jeunes des vieux avait des souvenirs
à raconter on les écoute
donc la tour cn itie à toronto va être
éteinte aujourd'hui en mémoire
d'elizabeth de oued beaucoup de
souvenirs dans cette ville merci
beaucoup merci à vous
alors on le disait en 70 ans de règne la
reine a connu douze premier ministre
canadien a été un modèle de de
neutralité politique c'est son rôle
n'affichant aucune préférence mais elle
avait quand même une affinité plus
grande pour certains d'entre eux
madeleine de la mort
de louis saint laurent à justin trudeau
12 premiers ministres se sont succédé
durant le long règne d'elizabeth
valeur
aux yeux
oui la reine en avait vu d'autres et
elle savait détendre l'atmosphère à sa
façon
merci de me faire sentir si vieille at
elle répondu à son 12e premier ministre
canadien sept ont été libérés aux cinq
conservateurs elle s'était toujours
gardé de montrer un penchant politique
la reine savait qu'elle était un symbole
bien au-delà de sa propre personnalité
elle devait donc par définition se tenir
au dessus des partis et au dessus des
premiers ministres bien que dans son for
intérieur il y a eu des affinités plus
grande avec certains qu'avec d'autres
jean chrétien et elle par exemple son
temps des biens au point où elle l'a
nommé dans le groupe sélect de l'ordre
du mérite
il réussissait à la fait rire comme lors
de ce moment marquant de l'histoire du
pays le rapatriement de la constitution
en 1982 le premier ministre hugo vient
juste de briser sa plume fontaine
chrétienne peut s'empêcher de murmurer
mer il est devenu rouge ou vert de honte
mais il s'est rendu compte que sa
majesté riet alors ils zappent est 2ème
et le voisinage la sincérité mais elles
appréciées peut être moins selon cet
historien le cabotinage de pierre
elliott trudeau elle qui avait accepté
de respecter tant de conventions pendant
tant d'années c'était pour trude autres
sa petite manière à lui un enfant
turbulent de 55 ans d'affirmer qu'il ne
s'en laissait pas imposé par la propre
et le protocole et qu'il est resté lui
même mais il note qu'il faut lire dans
les feuilles de thé pour déceler ses
sentiments ses préférences ou même des
signaux plus politique après l'échec de
l'accord du lac meech en 1990 elle s'est
toutefois permis un message en cette
journée de la fête du canada
je souhaite est plus profond du coeur
que les canadiens s'unissent et demeure
ensemble au lieu d'insister sur les
différences c'est vraiment le pas le
plus long qu elle pouvait franchir pour
exprimer un certain penchant de
compromis et d'ouverture vers le québec
où le fait français et le premier
ministre mulroney a été profondément
émus de cette prise de position de la
reine qui n'était pas du tout prêt
script et si elle tenait à s'élever au
delà de la partisanerie son d'image ce
qu'elle représentait on fait partie de
l'identité politique de certains premier
ministre comme john diefenbaker c'était
un homme de la vieille époque même en
son temps et il était profondément
pro-britanniques pro monarchie trop
commonwealth autant dans ses sentiments
que dans sa diplomatie ou steven rappelé
que son gouvernement avait fait
remplacer des toiles d'alfred pellan au
ministère des affaires étrangères par un
portrait de la reine pour le premier
ministre à peu la reine elizabeth 2
représentait qu l'antidote à certaines
valeurs libérales
progressiste moderniste avec l'arrivée
au pouvoir de justin trudeau les
tableaux du peintre québécois ont
retrouvé leur place
l'actuel premier ministre qui la
connaissait depuis son enfance à
démontrer davantage d'attachement pour
elle que pour la monarchie
il évoque son regard juste sur les
affaires du monde après avoir côtoyé
autant de premiers ministres canadiens
qui avaient leur personnalité et leurs
idées propres elle devait forcément
faire preuve d'une certaine sagesse ici
madeleine blé morin radio canada ottawa
[Musique]
question vous pourriez haut
les pilotes
[Musique]
j'ai envie de vérifier ses avis
comme en plus bon désir est que dans les
années à venir
[Musique]
venez et rester en vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça me vaut le détour
c'est moi qui je suis
[Musique]
suite à ce fait
qu'est-ce que shell
doit elle mais je risque âme de guerrier
mme kroes
frustrant ou elle vous fait
[Musique]
oui
énerve doublé
longue life
le pense pas mais l'immense terre
c'est
[Musique]
assez
stiles
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames messieurs alors nous
allons vous montrer des images qui nous
parviennent en direct de londres à
buckingham palace où il est maintenant
22 heures les britanniques continuent de
se rassembler vous le voyez malgré la
pluie pour celle qui aura été leur
pilier pendant 70 ans par sa constance
sa résilience son flegme aussi tellement
britannique la mort d'elizabeth ii a
donc été annoncé à 13h30 heure de l'est
sur twitter autre signe que les temps
changent
sa famille était à son chevet dans son
fils aîné charles qu'on appellera plus
le prince charles désormais puisqu'il
faudra s'habituer il est devenu
maintenant le roi charles iii
immédiatement après le décès de sa mère
c'est donc un véritable monument qui
nous quittent pour le royaume-uni oui
mais aussi pour le reste de la planète
de nombreux chefs d'état ont déjà offert
leurs condoléances doléances voici
d'abord un retour sur sa vie avec azeb
wolde giorgis
c'est le terme d'une vie guidée par le
devoir elizabeth ii s'était éteinte
aujourd'hui elle aura régné sur deux
siècles le plus long règne d'un monarque
c'est dès l'âge de 21 ans 1947 qu'elles
prêtent serment à la vie publique
elle dit alors des voué sa vie à ces
sujets et à la grande famille impériale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette même année elle épouse philippe
mambasa prince de grèce de danemark puis
c'est la naissance de charles et dan en
1952 alors qu'elle est au kenya son père
le roi george six meurt des suites d'une
longue maladie et comme le veut la
constitution elle devient
automatiquement rennes
le 2 juin 1953 c'est le couronnement
retransmis pour la première fois en
direct sur les télévisions et les radios
du monde entier à 26 ans la princesse
devient désormais reine elizabeth ii le
peuple se réjouit
durant son règne à l'heure a connu 14 le
président américain quinze premiers
ministres britannique et de nombreux
chefs d'état des pays du commonwealth
elle verra aussi l'éclatement de
l'empiré britannique et l'indépendance
des colonies on lui connaît deux
passions les chevaux et les chiens
son parcours de monarque aura été sans
faute mais sa vie privée aura été
ébranlé par les trois divorces très
publique de ses enfants notamment celui
du prince charles avec la princesse
diana
en 1997 à son décès la monarchie est
très impopulaire on lui reproche des
détachés du peuple par rapport à une
princesse diana qui avait gagné le coeur
des anglais
avec les années la monarchie se montre
plus accessible la cote de popularité de
la reine remontent peu à peu surtout
après le décès de sa mère la reine mère
en 2002 suivie du décès de sa soeur la
princesse margaret
en juin 2016 la reine est fêté en grande
pompe pour ses 90 ans au palais de
buckingham palace 1500 soldats en
uniforme 300 chevaux ont défilé pour
cette cérémonie baptisée trooping the
cradle la reine c'est lui ces sujets
entouré de toute la famille royale un
ensemble vert pomme pour bien marquer
l'occasion
plus de 60 coups de canon sont tirés de
la tour de londres pour rendre hommage à
son règne
le 9 avril 2021 elle perd son compagnon
de toujours le prince philip qui a été à
ses côtés pendant 74 ans
aujourd'hui les britanniques se retrouve
orphelin de celle qui aura régné plus de
60 ans en grande-bretagne durant son
règne la reine n'aura jamais accordé
d'entrevue elle aura gardé cette réserve
qui leur a finalement préservé ici à des
balayeurs guise radio canada montréal
[Musique]
on retrouve tout de suite nous inviter
deux passionnés de la monarchie estelle
boutillier et marc laurendeau
journalistes analystes alors évidemment
ce qui frappe avec
7,2 ce décès marque je vais commencer
avec vous c'est peut-être la longévité
de cette de cette reine nous n'avons
connu que cette monarque britannique
pour pour la plupart des gens ce que
nous vivons aujourd'hui c'est historique
c'est un changement de depok d'air parce
que du en effet comme vous le dites la
plupart des gens n'ont connu qu'elle est
sans son comportement exemplaire je
pense que la monarchie accord connu
beaucoup plus soubresauts si ç'avait été
un monarque ou monarque un peu des cas
d'un lisons les oncles de victoria
qu'ils avaient précédé sur le trône
avait été ce type de mon arc qui avait
semé un peu du scandale elles n'ont
elles étaient elles gardées le cap sur
son devoir et en ce sens là il recueille
l'adhésion de tout le monde alors ça
c'est à retenir il y aura aussi des
changements dans les moeurs je parlais
de changement d'ère jadis à une époque
notre cour d'appel du québec s'appelait
la cour du banc de la reine
et les avocats qui ont dix ans de
pratique ce sont des conseillers de la
reine ce sont des seront désormais des
conseillers du roi ils redoutent un
nouveau vocabulaire qu'une nouvelle
situation à laquelle va falloir
s'habituer charles toi puisque ce sera
son nom est un monarque qui dont les
intéresse je sais pas s'ils étaient
aussi intéressés par le commonwealth
qu'elisabeth 2 ce sera plus difficile
pour lui à cause de la réaction anti
coloniale mais l'huissier environnement
et voir s'ils vont réussir à une cause
très moderne soignante parenthèse et en
ce sens là il est un peu visionnaire
mais votre fils réussir à quoi avec son
obligation de réserve à imposer ça il
faut qu'ils fassent des campagnes qu'il
participe à des organisations
humanitaire pour promouvoir
l'environnement il pourrait pas le faire
directement ce produit tu passes les
projets de loi mais ça peut tuer une
heure environnementalistes que celle de
charles ça c'est une hypothèse mais
certainement que
sa mère aurait été exemplaire aura aussi
boucher les fissures quand tu as eu tous
ces scandales
de vie privée dans la famille elle
gardait ya beaucoup parler depuis
plusieurs années c'est elle qui en voie
de l'être à diana après son entrevue à
la bbc à l'émission panorama et qui lui
dit elle envoie une lettre je pense
qu'elle envoie diana et de sa propre
main leur manuscrite il faudra
maintenant vous pensiez à divorcer c'est
à dire et c'est elle qui est un peul
arbitres de ces situations là comme on
imagine que dans la sphère de meggen et
harry elle a eu son mot à dire parce
qu'elle ne pouvait pas accepter que
quelqu'un qu'une équipe qu'une souris
une branche de la famille et tous les
avantages de la monarchie la liste
civile c'est à dire les revenus mais ne
participe pas en même temps ou aux
oeuvres caritatives à toute la
représentation que ça suppose même si
charles était un peu le gérant tout ça
c'est du cavaly fond la reine a
certainement dû être consulté là dessus
son règne et coûté plus d'une vingtaine
de visites au canada certaines très
controversées comme le fameux samedi de
la matraque mais toutes celles plus
glorieuses à l'époque des fans becker en
effet à l'époque la canalisation du
saint laurent
d'autres
évidemment sur harper sous la coupe sur
la colline parlementaire à ottawa
c'était absolument
glorieux et l'appui au canada elles
faisaient ces espèces de marche dans la
foule avec beaucoup de plaisir semblé
t-il pour avoir couvert de ces de ces
événements-là
elisabeth était très apprécié d'un bout
à l'autre du canada le cas du québec est
spéciale mais ailleurs là que ce soit
dans l'ouest où les maritimes c'est
extraordinaire l'accueil qu'ils avaient
alors lyonnais attachement oui nous
changeons d'ère va falloir s'habituer
c'est une autre époque dans lesquels
nous entrons oui on va pendant qu'on
voit des images de la reine avec le
premier ministre harper qui appréciait
beaucoup elizabeth 2 mai mme bouthillier
malgré toutes les controverses dont marc
parlait qui est qu'a traversée la
famille royale surtout au cours des
dernières années la reine reste est très
aimé des britanniques elle était comme
un peu au dessus de tout ça les
britanniques ne lui en ont jamais voulu
pour toutes si on n'atteint jamais tenu
responsable pour tout ça mais qu'est ce
que vous allez retenir surtout de son
règne est ce que c'est son sens du
devoir parce qu'elle n'était pas destiné
à ce rôle et pourtant elle s'est dévouée
à la monarchie toute sa vie jusqu'à la
toute fin d'ailleurs oui comme vous le
dites elle n'était pas destiné à régner
puisque quand elle est née en 1926 son
oncle
le prince de galles de l'époque
devait éventuellement après la mort de
georges 2,5 devenir roi c'est ce qui est
arrivé en 1936 en janvier 36 et mais
pendant quelques années auparavant le
prince avait rencontré wallis simpson
est bon là on sait que pendant l'année
la question de lui voulait marier wallis
simpson mais les gens étaient elles
étaient comme elle était divorcée il
n'était pas question que on accepte que
le roi marie une divorcée donc lé 11
décembre 1936 le roi édouard 8 à
abdiquer en faveur de son frère le
prince albert qui est devenu le roi
george vi alors on voit là le prince
avait le prénom albert mais il a décidé
de changer de prénom d'aller vers george
plutôt que de conserver son prénom
d'albert pour lui pour eux c'était comme
comme le roi georges 5 avait été là
pendant plusieurs années plus de 25 ans
c'était comme une continuité et ça
permettait aussi un peu d'oublier la
parenthèse du roi édouard rude qui est
devenu par la suite le duc de windsor
mais la reine
par le fait même était devenu
l'héritière mais il était en 1936 il
était toujours possible que la reine
elizabeth la reine mère puisse avoir un
autre enfant qui soit si ç'avait été un
garçon il aurait pris là il arrêtait lui
le premier et elisabeth la deuxième mais
comme ils n'ont pas eu d'autres enfants
seulement il y avait eu la princesse
margaret qui est né en 1930 donc c'est
au fil des ans ils se sont rendus compte
que le couple royal n'aurait pas d'autre
enfant alors très rapidement
on a commencé à initier la princesse
elisabeth à ses futurs devoir elle n'a
jamais été à l'école d'une façon
formelle mais elle a eu des tuteurs et
le eu des des professeurs qui venait du
collège des etines qui tout près de
windsor venir lui faire
lui enseigner
l'histoire
à travers
l'histoire de la grande-bretagne et tout
ce qui touche l eau le côté judiciaire
donc quand elle est évidemment elle n'a
pas pensé elle n'a jamais cru qu elle
deviendra indigènes bon ensuite ya eu la
guerre elle a participé à l'effort de
guerre dès qu'elle a eu 18 ans elle a
décidé de d'être membre des ats c'est un
groupe fut menée qui s'occupe elle l a
été l chauffer des clients des camions a
été mécanicien losail exact alors elle a
fait et le prince celui qui est devenu
son mari par la suite le préfet les
pluies il était dans la marine il a
servi pendant toute la garde
la marine royale donc et mais après la
guerre
là évidemment le roi george vi la reine
isabelle la reine-mère ils ont
recommencé à faire des grands voyages à
l'international ils en ont fait un en
afrique du sud et au retour on a annoncé
que la princesse isabelle se marier avec
le prince philip et par la suite bien la
haye les deux il ya eu le mariage la
naissance rapide de deux enfants mais
tout en continuant en faisant des
représentations officielles parce que la
santé du roi george vi se détériorer
leur rapidement et à ce moment là elle
était d'ailleurs en voyage officiel
au kenya lorsque elle a appris qu'elle
était devenue reine et elle est rentrée
évidemment au pays tout de suite le lent
mais pour
évidemment diriger le deuil mais aussi
le prend de ses nouvelles fonctions
qu'ils l'ont amené leurs faisceaux elle
avait 25 ans et jusqu'à deux jours avant
sa mort elle à assumer ses devoirs de
soirée beau temps mauvais temps elle
était là et parce qu'il ya deux jours on
l'a vu donc on a vu cette photo cette
photo qui existent de sa dernière
rencontre avec la nouvelle première
ministre
les autres os oui on la voit quand même
assez assez en forme alliende amaigri
elle est affaiblie mais elle est
souriante est bon ce qu'a fait beaucoup
jaser c'est évidemment sa main parce que
ça peut être que ça traduisait une
certaine fragilité évidemment mais ça
s'est détériorée très vite
on espère que on saura exactement la
cause du décès mais même si on a la
connais pas et reste que bon c'est
évident c'est une personne âgée de santé
fragile et on sait très bien qu'à ses
angelots
rien peut faire que tout bascule est sur
le départ alors là maintenant ce qu'il
faut penser c'est évidemment
la fage la femme la souveraine c'est une
image publique mais il faut penser aussi
à la mer là le côté familial c'est une
famille qui commençait un deuil qui va
être difficile parce que on sait
justement il ya eu des périodes
extrêmement difficile dans les dernières
années avec un supplément de la famille
alors comment tout cela va se gérer
l'eau en fin de parenthèse on on rend
hommage à la souveraine on écarte les
mésententes les malentendus et à mais
après ça va falloir que
les choses vont reprendre leur de
nombreux défis pour le nouveau le cas
pour le roi gens le croient justement un
petit mot avant de voir plus en détail
le protocole à ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains jours marque sur sur ce
que vous retenez au niveau de son rôle
de monarque qu'elle prenait très au
sérieux la ligue tous les tous les jours
les documents dans les fameuses boîtes
rouges elle rencontrait le premier
ministre ponctuellement à chaque semaine
elle prenait ce devoir de rennes très au
sérieux oui
un exemple c'est la crise de suez dans
lequel guilde gouvernement britannique
'the sur un tony hidden à passer à
l'attaqué avec la france et israël avec
la désapprobation des états unis la
reine ont lu ces documents là et a
beaucoup interrogé sur un tony qui donne
sur son rôle politique est un événement
dont on j'aimerais qu'on se rappelle si
l'irlande le courage qu'elle a eu son
l'oncle de son mari de normand mbaye a
été assassiné par les sioux l'élire
révolutionnaire irlandais elle y va elle
rencontre martin mcguinness le chemin
des chefs de l'ieom maintenant devenir
chef politique légitime elle lui sert la
main et a fait des discours de
réconciliation en irlande elle revêtait
des vêtements qu'ils portent du trèfle
ou qui étaient verts y avait dans son
attitude dans ce voyage dans ce désir de
réconciliation
beaucoup de hauteur
son rôle aussi pour la fin du comme de
l'apartheid ou bien pour le commonwealth
et même si elle devait garder une
certaine réserve elle réussissait quand
même à faire passer les messages qu'elle
voulait passer tout à fait je pense que
wayne rooney pourrait vous en parler
elle rencontré les premiers ministres et
tentait de les sensibiliser à la cause
de l'apartheid j'ajouterai une affaire
qui est d'un peu de gens se souviennent
elles avaient un fabuleux yat le
britannia mais c'est la dengue sur ce
yacht qu'elle trouvait la liberté il ya
des images de ce sont des images
d'archivés leur plaisir fou à voyager
avec soya mais ça coûtait les fortunes
en pétrole et l asus a été déchirant
après avoir baptisé ce bateau et avoir
vécu des heures extraordinaire elle dut
abandonner se débarrasser du britannia
par les citoyens de grande bretagne se
serrer la ceinture ça n'était pas décent
de garder un bateau pareil et à grand
regret c'est de regret de sa vie
d'ailleurs elle le dit elle a dû se
dessaisir du britannia
il ya quand même eu dans sable dans sa
longue carrière des gestes d'abnégation
comme cela qu'ils montraient qu'il avait
une certaine hauteur encore une fois
c'est le sens du devoir con con qu'on
perçoit moins que chez d'autres membres
de sa famille immédiate
je dirais même dans sa descendance
immédiate on les sent moins
active
lancé si on a de tels pouvoirs si on
reçoit de tels honneurs la réciproque
c'est qu'on doit être à la hauteur et
donc on doit non seulement appuyé à
remplir la tâche se tenir bien informés
et en comptait c'était hyper bien
informée elle faisait ses devoirs là on
a parlé des boîtes rouges elle se tenait
au courant de ce qui se discute et au
cabinet c'est fabuleux de rencontrer
chaque semaine tout à fait on va écouter
maintenant quelques réactions donc à ce
décès à londres
ce sens
[Musique]
oui
oui beaucoup de tristesse donc après l
annonce de cette disparition yasmine
parlons maintenant du protocole de ce
qui va se passer dans les prochains
jours on l'évoquait un peu plus tôt avec
as they must assez ça c'est gros seins
ce qui s'en vient oui et ça porte un nom
c'est loupé l'opération london bridge
c'est ce qui va se passer c'est ce qui
va se dérouler dire durant les dix
prochains jours donc qui suivent le
décès de la reine c'est une habitude de
préparer à l'avance le des cds
souverains
c'était le cas pour georges 6
l'opération portait le nom de wright
park corner pour le prince philippe ça
s'appelait faute bridge pour la reine
d'angleterre donc la défunte reine
elizabeth c'est l'opération london
bridge qui commence aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui étant le d'idées de cette
opération donc le jour j voyons voir ce
qui s'est passé donc dès l'annoncé de la
mort est bien le secrétariat particulier
de la reine en informer la première
ministre avec le nom de code le pont de
londres s'est effondré il a également
informé les quinze gouvernement aux 15
états dont la souveraine était la chef
ainsi que les 36 pays du commonwealth il
y a eu également des dépêches qui sont
sortis on a avisé les médias et on a vu
également pendant la journée le logo de
la bbc donc l'équivalent du service
public britannique se transformer passer
du rouge au noir les animateurs
également été habillés de noir et sur la
devanture de buckingham palace un homme
habillé en noir accroché une image qui
ressemble à la à cette photo qu'on a
pris du site de la famille royale sur
l'ensemble des plateformes de la famille
royale on pouvait lire le message
succinct la reine est décédé à balmoral
cet après midi le roi et la reine
consort resteront à balmoral ce soir et
reviendront à londres demain avec la
date d'aujourd'hui on ne sait l'annoncé
a été faite et tout de suite après bien
les drapeaux ont été mis en berne il
fallait respecter une durée limite de
temps de 10 minutes pour pouvoir tous
les baisser on le sait également le
parlement ainsi que les législatures
connexes dos des autres des autres pays
de la nouvelle écosse de l'irlande du
nord et également
de l'ecosse ont été mis en berne demain
par contre les les drapeaux vont
reprendre de leur superbe parce qu'à 11h
et bien charles sera intronisé
officiellement roi et sa femme camilla
vous deviendra à rennes c'était
également le veut et la volonté et le
désir de la défunte reine elizabeth par
la suite le roi charles va se rendre en
écosse au pays de galles en irlande du
nord pour assister à des cérémonies
commémoratives en hommage à la mémoire
de la reine défunte juste avant les
funérailles par la suite et pendant ce
temps là est bien le westminster sera
complètement fermée on va tout
réaménager et par la suite au jour j + 4
et bien on va exposer le corps de la de
la défunte et pendant quatre jours on
prévoit le protocole prévoit que cinq
cent mille personnes pourront venir se
recueillir et rendre hommage un dernier
hommage posthume à la reine avant les
funérailles officielles qui vont se
dérouler à la chapelle de westminster
le dixième jour et elle sera par la
suite inhumé aux côtés de son défunt
mari le prince philip et de thau son
défunt père georges 6 à la chapelle de
windsor mais alors la semaine vous
disiez que c'est demain dans quinze
heures que le conseil d'adhésion on va
se réunir à sainte gemmes pour proclamer
charles donc charles iii roi
officiellement mais en fait il n'y a pas
eu de vie du tout 1,2 selon la
l'institution monarchique britannique le
au moment où sa mère est décédée il est
devenu immédiatement le prochain
monarque donc il est devenu roi à ce
moment là le roi est mort vive le roi
exact merci à ce milieu je vous en prie
et on va les retrouver minutes est
toujours devant un rideau hall à ottawa
louis évidemment il ya eu des réactions
un peu partout dans le monde et la
classe politique canadienne a aussi
réagi parlons d'abord de celle de justin
trudeau qui reconnut la reine quand il
était enfant
ou est tout petit alors que son père
était premier ministre et lui comme
premier ministre plus tard le premier
ministre trudeau qui a dit que le canada
est en deuil on a vu des réactions d'un
bout à l'autre du pays céline
aujourd'hui justin trudeau qui a tenu à
décrire la reine elizabeth 2 comme étant
sage curieuse drôle même il dit qu'il a
eu beaucoup de plaisir à beaucoup
apprécié les moments où il avait des
discussions en tête à tête avec elle au
fil de son mandat comme premier ministre
il est son 12e premier ministre l'a tenu
à souligner l aconit 12 des 23 premiers
ministres canadiens c'est pas peu dire
il faut savoir que la reine était très
attaché au canada elle dit qu à l
arrivée ici elle disait qu'elle avait
l'impression de revenir à la maison
enfin deux voyages au canada écoutons si
vous voulez y avait en fait je mentionne
juste avant de passer aux extraits jean
chrétien aussi l'ancien premier ministre
est prêt de la réserve et 2 qui a réagi
qu'il a qualifié de dévoués respecter
agréable aussi en prévu et dit qu'elle
méritait le respect qu'on lui démontre
aujourd'hui on peut entendre maintenant
justin trudeau suivi de quelques
premiers ministres provinciaux
dans un monde très compliqué
sa présence sa graff
sa force
a été une ressource importante
pour nous tous
c'était une de mes personnes préféré au
monde
et elle me manquera énormément
ta rennes 2 a marqué les esprits par sa
force par son calme ou si elle était
pourtant aux premières loges des grands
événements du 20e siècle donc c'est un
grand personnage historique qui nous
quitte et je demandais que le drapeau du
québec soit en berne sur tous les
édifices publics du gouvernement
j'aimerais offrir toutes mes
condoléances
sa majesté le roi charles iii j'aimerais
également félicité sa majesté à
l'occasion son ascension autres ont
dormi et dui souhaité tous les succès
dans la continuité de l'héritage de sa
mère
nous nous rappellerons très longtemps
des générations vont se rappeler d'elle
dans les jours à venir les gens partout
dans la province et dans le monde entier
on s'est rassemblé pour se rappeler
toute une vie dévouée à tant de causes
nobles
il ya beaucoup de citoyens ordinaires
celles et tous ceux qui ont voulu rendre
hommage à la reine elizabeth ii regardez
ici les fleurs qui ont été déposées
devant la statue d'elizabeth ii on est
devant reed or à l'extérieur voyez ici
qui trompe sur ce cheval devant rideau à
des gens à qui on a parlé ici qui nous
disent qu'ils qui en les écoutant on a
l'impression que c'est comme si j'avais
un liens très personnels avec la
monarque qui vient de s'éteindre
aujourd'hui donc on sent que les gens
appréciaient beaucoup la personne on
sait que les canadiens de plus en plus
se détache de l'institution qu'est la
monarchie on sait que aussi le roi
charles iii est pas aussi populaire
qu'ils habitent deux même que le prince
william selon les derniers sondages que
j'ai consultés qu'ils ont été menées ces
derniers mois auprès des canadiens
prince william est à peu près deux fois
plus populaire que le prince charles à
lui en termes d'image c'est sûr qu'au
canada il aura une pente à remonter la
visiter le canada d'ailleurs au cours
des derniers mois il s'était rendu à
terre-neuve notamment rappelez-vous
alors sans doute qu'on verra
éventuellement d'autres voyages comme
cela je vous mentionne qu'il y aura ici
vivent de signatures les gens vont
pouvoir venir les mains du public signé
pour exprimer leurs condoléances dont un
grand livre de condoléances on attend de
voir si un petit peu plus tard
aujourd'hui la gouverneure générale mais
ça ne va prendre la parole prononcé une
allocution au canadien on surveille ça
en tout cas on reste ici certainement
pour une partie de ce courriel a déjà
réagi mais par communiqué vous parlez
louis de l'attachement de l'attachement
des canadiens envers la reine mais la
reine avait aussi un attachement
particulier avec le canada c'est le pays
qu'elle a visité le plus souvent dans
son rôle et je sais qualif qu'elle ait
fait beaucoup de voyages dans sa vie
donc merci louis on va aller retrouver
benoît ferrat
direction là bas elle a visité cette
fois il à colombie britannique
oui vous parlez des voyages la reine
avait un lien particulier avec la
colombie britannique elle avait dit une
histoire d'amitié cette fois la première
fois en 1951 alors qu'elle n'était que
princesse dernière fois en 2002 et en
2002 quand la reine avait visité vaincu
vancouver à l'avait fait la mise au jeu
d'une partie de roque et des canucks des
images qui avaient fait à l'époque le
tour du monde on est dans un pub ici où
il ya un hommage spécial qui est rendus
à l'arène toute la journée les
consommations sont à moitié prix c'est
une anecdote mai les c'est un des rares
endroits ici où les britanniques
expatriés à vancouver peuvent se
rassembler en un peu plus de 30000
britanniques expatriés ici à vancouver
et la direction ici tenait à rendre
hommage les télévisions sont sur
radio-canada et cybit si toute la
journée et on attend ici beaucoup de
monde après la journée de travail pour
partager une boisson parler de la reine
et rendre hommage je vous propose
d'écouter des autres vu qu'on vient de
réaliser avec la direction et quelques
clients ici
j'ose espérer que
beaucoup de gens d'outre-mer vont venir
peut-être prendre un verre rendre
hommage d'une certaine façon
souveraine ce n'est pas uniquement pour
l'alcool au fond mais c'est juste de se
rassembler comme que noté moi j'ai été
attristée car à sauver vous c'est la
seule marque j'ai connu en fait elle est
notre reine également là bien c'est
toujours une bonne façon de rendre
hommage à la reine
et on a ici aussi à vancouver quelques
magasins qui sont spécialisés des
magasins britanniques ou les
britanniques se retrouvent pour acheter
leur spécialité on s'est rendu dans un
magasin aussi plus tôt et on a vu
plusieurs gens qui rendait hommage et
qui a racheté par exemple des drapeaux
pour pouvoir rendre hommage à la reine
d'angleterre aujourd'hui
mon drapeau du pays de galles celui de
l'ecosse de l'ue canada de la suède mais
pensez-vous que j'aurais pu trouver un
drapeau de la grande bretagne eh ben non
mais ça me prenait ça
et pour terminer on vient de rencontrer
ici un québécois d'origine galloise qui
ne voulait pas s'exprimer mais qui nous
a dit qu'il était vraiment extrêmement
triste de voir ce le décès de la reine
d'angleterre aujourd'hui et il compte
également célébrer et rendre hommage à
la reine ce soir à beaucoup vers merci
moi
oui comme le disait un des intervenants
de benoît ilité tutelle c'est la seul
monarque beaucoup de gens ont connu et
je vois que marie-eve et la marie-eve
qui est arrivé donc allons notre
correspondante marie-eve parlez nous un
petit peu on le dit depuis le début de
cette émission que c'est un peu un choc
une même c'est pas une très grande
surprise mais pour beaucoup de
britanniques c'est vraiment un moment
très très triste parlez-nous de l'état
d'esprit un petit peu chez là bas
c'est un moment très solennel céline il
s'était préparé les britanniques à ce
moment on avait célébré ses 70 ans de
règne la dernière fois que j'étais ici à
buckingham palace on avait aperçu la
reine mais très affaibli sur le balcon
qui déjà avait dû annuler plusieurs de
ses participations aux élèves et aux
événements qui devait célébrer son règne
donc il à rennes les gens il était très
attaché et aujourd'hui ils ont besoin de
se rassembler pour partager ce qui est
un moment historique
vous l'avez dit l'après vaste majorité
des gens n'ont connu que la reine
elizabeth sur le compte c'est le cas des
gens qui affluent ici à buckingham
palace depuis l'annoncé de sa mort cet
après midi les gens viennent se
recueillir viennent parler entre eux
viennent déposer des fleurs ça se fait
avec beaucoup d'émotion mais dans la
sobriété